okay good morning everyone can i welcome
everyone to this meeting of development
control committee a mid-south district
council
can i just run through some of the
domestic arrangements before we make a
start can i ask you please to ensure
that microphones are turned off when not
in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations while the
meeting is in progress if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave and can i ask
everyone just to double check mobiles
are on silent
or switched off and also could i ask you
to turn the volume down we just heard it
then on laptops so that we don't have
pinging of messages every time they come
in please
um
we will be using e-voting for members
that are able to unfortunately i have a
new laptop and it's not downloaded
properly but if you have got e-voting
we will be using e-voting
so if you could just make sure you are
logged on to the app please
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and be capable of repeated
viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded and by
entering the meeting as a speaker you're
also consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph will
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if we do hear the fire alarm sound today
please can you leave the building
immediately by the fire exit to make our
uh make your way to the assembly point
at ipswich town football club follow the
signs directing you to the fire exit at
each end of the floor and please do not
enter the atrium the ground floor area
and walkways if you're in the atrium
when the alarm sounds please follow the
signs to the nearest fire exit
please use stairs and please do not use
the lifts and please do not re-enter
until we're told it is safe to do so
good okay so we now just run through um
who's in the room just for the benefit
of members of the public who may not
have been to a planning meeting before
so we have on my
left
we have
five ward members and myself
elected members who'll make a decision
on the applications before us today
in mid-southwark a local member may
speak on an application but may not vote
um we also have uh some other ward
members present uh who will come forward
at various times councillor geek and
council muller who'll be called and
counselor uh
carter as well who will call to come
forward for applications in their wards
uh and then case officers will come
forward uh during the meeting and we
have philip isabel gemma walker in de
pres
alex scott
avril goody and then to support the
meeting
and then most importantly either side
and we have the people that make the
meeting tick over and run so thanks
everyone for your support today
first item on the agendas apologies for
absence and substitutions do we have any
please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor rick mayer councillor barry
humphries and council sarah mansell
councillor wellam is substituting for
sarah mansell thank you
i know a couple of those uh found out
this last night that one of them
particularly picked up covered so um
couldn't be here at such short notice
and the other phone didn't sit this
morning so apologies we couldn't get
substitutions which is what we'd
normally try and do
okay do we need to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
yes cancer even
thank you chair yes on on item seven um
a which is um the elmsell one in law
homes and my brother works for bloor
homes
councilman yes thank you chair yes i'd
like to report i am vice chair of stone
market town council planning committee
and when this item was brought before
the committee i left the room and took
no part in the debate
or the vote and i'm also a director of
cedars park art thank you
okay
um thank you for those any dec oh sorry
councilwoman
thank you chair um yes i'm county
councillor for
the the division which includes cedars
park thank you thank you
okay uh
declarations of lobbying i've been
lobbied on the bloor homes something
came in the post uh yesterday
um anyone else yeah that's all of us on
the committee thank you
okay yep thank you
okay
any declarations of personal site visit
by members that's none oh yep council
rebound
okay thank you
okay we're not going to move to the
minutes of the meeting that was held on
the 4th of may
uh that's in our papers um
we start on page 5
and run through to page nine
is everyone happy that i signed those as
a true record
oh sorry we have to have an electronic
vote sorry
yes
on page seven um
164.5
and effectively 164.7
i did think that the given that all all
seven members of the committee expressed
their
particular disappointment regarding the
the um
the estate being connected to the gas
grid um that really that should have
actually come through explicitly in the
minutes
um so i don't know what other people
think but i i did
i did that did strike me that that that
didn't
get minuted
but it was a pretty central point of the
discussion actually
okay can i suggest what we do is let's
not sign them off let's just go back and
just listen to the tape and just see if
there's something that just double check
what was said and get put that in and
bring it back yeah cancer event
chair we could just say because it's got
proposed heating systems we could put
proposed heating systems especially the
gas grid
regarding the gas grid after proposed
heating systems i'm happy with that
everyone else happy okay so on that
basis are we happy to go to a vote yes
yeah proposed by council pass more
secular by council eben will now go to
an electronic vote
thank you members that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that's five votes four
and one abstentions carried thank you
very much
thank you very much
okay
um i now need to move on to
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petitions scheme are
there any received
non-received chat okay so we're going to
move now on to the schedule of the
planning applications i'm just going to
do the order slightly differently i'm
going to do 7c first and then go to 7a
and 7b
so we're going to start off with 7c
which is in our papers on page
217
and now hand over to the case officer
avril goody
thank you chair hello members so the
application before you today is located
at the intersection of gun cottage way
and linux drive in stone market
and the proposal is full planning
application for
two art displays
so this is the location you've got gun
cotton way running west to east along
here and linux drive north to south
so there's two locations you have a
which is central within this roundabout
which is proposed for the main artwork
and then you have b on the highways
verge to the north east which is
proposed for the information board
so there's the aerial map there you can
see you've got cedars park estate to the
north
and
the land to the south there is currently
under construction
and then just some wider context
obviously you've got tesco's um to the
northeast
cedars to the north and then some more
commercial units further to the the west
there
and then in terms of constraints so that
there isn't any particular constraints
on the site you can just see there that
the orange denotes the
speed limit which is 30 miles an hour
and in terms of the artwork proposed so
this is the main artwork the one that's
proposed
to be located centrally on the
roundabout
so the design is six birds above
a plow
it's proposed to be 3.5 metres high
and
1.5 meters wide
the materials are proposed as steel
and it will be located on a concrete
plymph which is going to be 1.6 meters
hot and two meters wide
and then this is the information board
so that's proposed to be 0.8 meters high
um and located yeah on the grass verge
adjacent to that roundabout and again
the materials will be steel
just in terms of some photographs here
you've got um facing towards
kind of southeast towards the roundabout
you can see
um
here
on gun custom way
and then a slightly zoomed in version
you can see the roundabout has
some hedging and then the chevrons um
there
and then facing northwest this time to
the opposite direction you've got the
roundabout there and then
you can see the grass verge where the
information board is proposed
and again just that is the location for
the information board
and just a slightly closer
photo of the
roundabout and then a photo looking
south on lynette drive
again you can see the hedge and the
chevrons there
just to say we have received some
additional comments from the highways
authority
just providing some additional
reasoning behind their initial comments
and they can be found in your table
papers
so the recommendation is for approval
subject conditions as set out in um on
page 20 222 of the bundle
thank you
can you just run through the additional
highways points uh yes
so um in their um initial comments um
they concluded that the um
the proposal wasn't considered to have a
significant impact on highway safety
um so they have just
we asked for some further details on why
that that was their conclusion
and ultimately they kind of considered
that
the roundabout is oval shaped so um
the problem the existing kind of
concerns probably relate to that shape
and the fact it does allow for users of
the highway to take that roundabout at
slightly higher speeds than maybe
desired
um
so essentially having the hedge and the
chevrons there
it wants to make people slow down you
don't want to be able to see across the
roundabout so it makes drivers yeah slow
down so essentially they've concluded
that um
having the artwork essentially in the
roundabout is not likely to cause any
further obstruction that than already is
experienced
and it's not going to reduce the
visibility to drivers that are on the
roundabout or waiting to join
thank you very much
uh questions any other questions
yeah councilwoman
yeah thank you i i couldn't see
precisely how far back from the edge of
the road the information board is meant
to is meant to be and also
if somebody wanted to go close to it i
mean it's got some wording on but people
might think well i ought to go have a
look at that how do they how do they
actually get there presumably they walk
round the hedge and then they're
standing on the verge
i believe it'll be in in front of that
hedge on the on the um verge so they'll
just walk across the grass um onto it
and it'll have
um i believe kind of some etchings on it
and a qr code that people can scan to
yeah i mean
i'm in danger of making a statement
rather than asking a question um
if if somebody wanted to
do that
would it not be better if they didn't
have to get onto the verge if they could
do that from that the other side of the
hedge so to speak
from the pavement yeah
let's ask the applicant when or okay
remember when we come to that maybe
thank you thank you for the invitation
no not no it's not now it's when we come
to you no problem
okay any other questions
no okay so we're gonna move on
um
okay so uh
we don't have
anyone from the town council but we have
first of all an objector bob cracknell
uh you have three minutes to speak and
we have a timer here and would ask that
you keep the three minutes please and
over to you when you're ready
thank you good morning everyone um my
name is bob cracknell i've lived on
cedars park in stone market for 19 years
the submitted objections universally
highlight the chosen location is
inappropriate whilst the choice of
artwork was put to a public vote the
location was not
the roundabout in question is the only
oval shaped one out of five along gun
cotton way
whether planned or not this promotes a
faster speed of entry and exit for
traffic along gun cotton way from the
direction of the town centre
the issue with the existing layout is
most apparent when approaching the
roundabout intending to turn right into
linux drive it's well documented in
eject in objectives comments
the common thread amongst supporters
comments is that the artwork would be
nice to look at and would add a feeling
of enrichment
if that is true then it would apply
wherever it was situated
if art is to be enjoyed by looking at it
then it's clearly odds with safe
attentive driving
there is no compelling argument for this
location to be considered essential
one comment i have seen speaks of a
reduced risk of vandalism
is that more important than road safety
i've spoken personally with the
commission blacksmith who's told me that
it could be located anywhere
25 locations were considered but the
project manager has refused to disclose
them
interestingly the addresses of
supporters would suggest that linux
drive is not their routine entry point
for the estate hence they may have
little appreciation of the situation
i've tried to convey
i was advised to email photographs to
you in advance to try and illustrate
this as i was told i would not be able
to introduce them today
to construct a 16 foot tall iron work on
this roundabout with the wide side
facing traffic on gun cotton way would
further hamper visibility across the
roundabout including hgv traffic
travelling from the tomo industrial
estate
i defy anyone using this identify anyone
to use this junction on a motorcycle and
tell me they feel safe doing so
the project manager has dismissed
objectors comments regards visibility
and refused to enter into discussion or
meeting at the proposed location where
opposing views could be explained or
understood
i would all venture that such a
significant number of supporting
comments for a planning application is
not the norm
a cynical person might think there's
been a deliberate effort to negate
objectives comments as such this is
hardly a community project which
community is it representing
it is within your gift and i would urge
you to conduct your own site visit to
understand the issue i repeat the issue
is turning right into linux drive it's
also important to recognize the issue
will duplicate once the housing
development opposite limit drive is
complete
if you are not minded to conduct a site
visit i would ask that you take time to
consider the public comments in full
before any decision is made as so much
context has been lost in summaries
from the associated papers i note the
highways officers comment that it is not
desirable to have through roundabout
visibility as it encourages higher
speeds
that is certainly not the case at the
moment yet this proposal would make a
poor situation far worse for no
justifiable
gain whilst the police may not have any
reports of serious injury or fatal
accidents at this location
every day near misses and damage only
collisions are not reported
the three minutes are up to the last
sentence please this artwork can go
anywhere lives are more important than
that
thank you thank you very much
okay any questions for the objective
no okay thank you for that
um we now move on to a supporter jenny
davidson and again oh sorry the
applicant my fault uh jenny davis and
the applicant and again you have three
minutes over to you please
thank you for um
inviting me today i i'm speaking
on behalf of the community
who has
uh
through
three councillors who are responsible
for our award
and the entire committee of cedars park
residents association
who worked for some 10 years towards
actually 10 years from today
to get a work of art on on cedars park
which uh in their minds was a bit of a
replacement for one that never did get
erected in the um in the precinct which
was planned and superseded by cdrs house
we had a question earlier which i called
to quickly cover fortunately i got the
notes in front of me the verge around
the hedging in the center of the
roundabout is three meters wide
so
i wouldn't encourage anybody to go
wandering
across that roundabout
the plan for the bollard is to have a
minimum amount of information but a link
to the council website which explains
all about it and a qr code as well so
that anybody that's got a smartphone can
can access that
there's no real intention for people to
get close to the work of art it's
elevated it's in the middle of a lot of
hedging
it's it's designed to be viewed from a
distance so um
i would say that
i can't i can't claim that there's no
risk
for people getting across to the
roundabout but but that's the case
with regard to location uh we started
this in november i've got some
correspondence here which was with
highways
back to the very beginning of november
2021
but we've tried from the start i've rung
the police to to check as to whether
they've got the view
uh on on past accidents i've searched in
the press
and so on so i don't think we've in any
way been negligent and every step that
i've taken along the way
has been
in
communicated
fully
partially through dave muller partly
partly through meetings that i've
attended and so on so i think it's
nothing's been done in secret
but what i can't do is
is deal with any individuals who've got
a different view
and and i would like to thank avril for
the absolutely superb summary that you
put together i i've already made
comments back to some of your colleagues
about that have also thank you
so i think you've covered it very very
well i don't need to go into the details
of the planning application
what i do need to do is to communicate
to you that this is a community project
people have been put a lot of time and
effort into this and what i don't want
to do is just match defeat from the
jewels of victory and i think i think
it's a worthwhile project
and and i've had a lot of support i've
had people stop their cars and and thank
me for what i'm doing i've had people
write to me to thank to to say well done
you know see it through
the three minutes are up so the last
sentence please i can close on that
thank you
okay any questions at all
okay
okay thank you very much thank you for
that now we move over to the ward member
councillor muller
very much chair yes i'd like to agree
with what um
mrs davidson's actually said on this um
i've actually been involved with this
project going back several years with
the cedars park residents association
we've met with officers of the council
on a regular basis and we continue to do
so
i have also spoken to a police officer
and discussed this with them and they
are of the opinion that it's not
dangerous at all and that concurs with
what the highways department has said
this particular piece of art we did
actually ballot residents at tesco's at
cedric's house and at the regal cinema
in stone market
and on those we had six foot high boards
at tesco's and it stated specifically
where the proposal was to cite this
piece of art
so residents who wrote it and there was
over 700 people actually voted 769 voted
altogether
for the piece of art
it actually ties in very well with
cedars park because originally there was
a roman
farm on cedars park
and obviously the fields would have been
plowed so and it's also relevant with
the birds because obviously all the
roads on cedars park are named after
birds
we've actually i've actually worked very
closely with the cedars park residents
association and the only reason that um
mrs davidson took over the project back
in november because during the pandemic
unfortunately no work was done on this
project and no meetings were held but
unfortunately due to ill health of the
members that were doing it from the
cedars park residents association
i asked jenny if she would actually take
over the project and she has actually
done so
i know the area well i live on cedars
park myself there is a footpath cycle
path all the way along gun cotton way
so there's no reason for cyclists to use
the the actual road
at all
we i've spoken to a number of people and
only in the last week several residents
have said to me personally they're
really looking forward to seeing this
piece of artwork in place we've worked
very very hard as a community to get
this together and i'm pleased to be able
to support the local community in seeing
this to its end
so we did look at other locations across
cedars park one of them that's been
mentioned i think by one of the
objectives is what the area known as big
park
the region reason we rejected that area
because it's well known there's lots of
children play on it it'll be more likely
to be vandalized and that particular
area is also subject to anti-social
behavior and in the past there has been
drug taking drug dealing going on there
because i've had meetings with the
police represented from the county and
the district council so we didn't want
it to go there i think the location is
perfectly safe and the majority of
comments i have had fully support this
application therefore i urge members to
uh approve this application uh today
thank you chair thank you and councillor
carter sorry i probably should have come
to you first alphabetically but over to
you
i'm always happy to listen to dave speak
as well so don't worry about that
yes i was very pleased to see this slide
where it's actually showing the
uh the view of the roundabouts
we do have a beautiful skyline there
and we are known as but we did get some
quite dramatic skies
and
we've had many areas of natural scenery
we've been robbed of over years and it'd
be shame to rob ourselves of this
opportunity to enhance the view
to give those who aren't driving a
moment to look up and enjoy
um
i have had some objections
come to me regards
obstructing the view of a roundabout
about cause and distraction of the
drivers
um yet you only have to travel further
long down the road for example some
roundabouts with advertising or
even big old orange construction
structure and fencing littering of you
and
these and parts haven't seemed to impact
his driving
other than to complain that they wish
that a beautiful enhancement has been
done there
and all things willingly at one point
they will be
and studies have shown as well that
um arts such as this
causing a dappled review through and
over prompts drivers into concentrating
harder into slowing down and improving
driving
and yes the shape of the roundabout
isn't ideal ideal for the speed but this
could improve upon it this could help
help it
and i've had fears as well about to be
artwork placed there about
possibility of vandalism when we've
heard again having to get over to a
hedge
people crossing the road it's not likely
to be going going for
um
[Music]
but we can't change human nature
basically once and it may want to damage
it may want to damage it but that's what
we have insurance for i don't think it's
going to cause any further risk of
people
um
what we have the opportunity here is to
actually give something to the locals to
actually the locals to call their own to
be proud of
a beloved lump in the middle of a road
um for people coming from and going to
stone market to admire along the way
i can't honestly think of a reason why
we shouldn't give ourselves a little
gift to the soul a little bit of artwork
there and i genuinely hope that you
can't eat you can't think of a reason
either
so thank you
thank you very much can i just ask i've
got a question questions for the ward
members um in terms of the longevity so
if it needs repair work in
three years because something happens to
it
do we know how that will be funded
um i can sorry am i yeah
um
yes we have a we have a surplus over and
above the cost of implementing the work
of art
um
we were able to insure it
for 10 years
that was a requirement after that in a
number of on that route a number of
things may occur
there's also uh
some sort of funding as well
for uh for repairs for vandalism i spoke
to uh david blackburn who's the the town
clerk
well back in
in early in the early stages of this and
and he said uh every time we put a piece
of work of art up in stone market
the vandals get to it that's what they
do with their spray cans so i think the
balance of probability is that there
will be some spraying in the early
stages
i looked up the cost of
clearing
spray paint etc off off a concrete wall
because the plinth will have that sort
of surround and it came out about 250
pounds
the other thing is i've embedded in the
contract with the blacksmith that if
physical damage occurs and and and i
have some
reassurance that the sections used will
be extremely difficult to damage but the
contract uh says that he will make them
good at cost
so we've got a we've got some head room
in in the budget which we're retaining
for that
thank you okay any other questions for
the ward members yes councilwoman thank
you chad could i ask the ward members do
you do you see a reason why it should be
in the i'm happy with the main piece of
art but the the information board do you
see a reason why it has to be where it's
shown on that drawing um
would you be happy if it were adjacent
to the cycle track footwear but it seems
to me that anyone who's going to come
and look at it
it looks as if it's
wrong side of the hedge
no it's uh thank you so well no it's
actually by the the cycle footwear right
so it won't impede the cycle footway but
it is actually next to that okay
thanks
okay
no other questions some members over to
you to discuss debate and come to a
conclusion yes council even first and
council mass
um thank you very much chair um i think
this is a very interesting project i can
understand the concerns from local
residents about the roundabout but i
think the concerns
actually relate more to the layout of
the roundabout
than the than the um than having the
artwork there
um and obviously we've got the the
comments from highways that um have
explained that that shouldn't be borne
out in terms of safety
overall i think there's there's artwork
on a lot of roundabouts everywhere you
know there's a lot in berries and
edmonds on the new estates and ipswich
they have artwork throughout their
estates and i think it's such a shame
that we don't have
uh so much in stomach if i hardly have
any on the new estates and stone market
and so i think this is very good to see
and i think i would like to see more of
it and i'd be happy to support it thank
you chair
thank you very much councillor madison
thank you chair well i
i um
i can i can
subject to have said 19 years um yeah
the when that roundabout was built it
was controversial it is it has been
described as lozenge shaped
and i never understood any justification
why that one was different from the
other ones
yes yes it makes it possible for people
to go around there quicker
and which is a great pity
they should all be the same and they
should all discourage as the highways uh
authority has said uh people from
belting around them too fast and and
that's all
all kind of um
fair enough really so i i don't
you know i don't think that the artwork
is changing
that the difficulty which is council
ebon's already said of the shape of the
roundabout
etc
and the other thing that
that struck me that i i recall
um
a long time ago now
at a planning committee agreeing that
there was going to be some artwork
um
sat on top of of i think it was a water
angling water installation which might
have been near hedge sparrow drive
i never heard why that didn't happen but
anyway i think i'm pleased to see that
at last eventually
public art is is going to be provided if
we if we agree to it so uh i i've you
know i've got no hesitation in actually
supporting it
um although i do know that
it was called here because it's it was
controversial and that there are almost
equal numbers of people are supporting
it and opposing it we didn't actually
hear from councillor muller what the um
the 769 people voted how how that split
down actually
if we may
thank thank you thank you councillor
matt said i have do have those figures
with me
just bear with me a second
yeah
basically as i say we we've had the
total was 769
of those six six voting papers were
spoiled
we had um in tesco's
305 supported the rural reflections
which is the one that you're seeing
today 114 supported one called the stone
market sheath and 251 supported the
fallen feathers in sidra's house 15
supported the rural reflections 15
supported stone market sheath and 26 for
fallen feathers and in the regal seven
supported the rural reflections 10
supported the stone market chief and 20
supported the fallen feathers so overall
we had a clear winner with with the
rural reflections that we have here
today
oh i see i was i was kind of assuming
that that they'd also been asked whether
they didn't like it at all
um and and objected to it but that
wasn't you know they had a choice
i think i mean it's a very good number
of people that participated yeah um
and i think there's probably some sport
ballot numbers are um
minimal so we can assume that most
people like the idea in general yeah and
i should add to that that the actual
count was actually undertaken at tesco's
and it was under the supervision of the
then term there stone market and also
the manager of tesco's that was
completely sure it was done in a proper
way thank you
uh council pastor uh thank you chairman
i've listened to the various discussions
there very carefully i do understand the
perspective um of the objective but i
think overall it is a good scheme and i
don't know if rachel you proposed
proposed it but i'm certainly happy to
do that or second it because i think um
it's a good idea and very pleased to see
it thank you
how's the feel
and you won't repeat what everybody else
has said uh
obviously artwork is a good thing to
have in this sort of location
i have to say i am a bit concerned about
the highways visibility issue um
we do seem to have highways persistently
telling us that uh the less you can see
the more safer it is um i i find that a
difficult concept but i have to accept
that they're highways engineers and i am
not so it's probably correct
um and
on that basis i'm quite happy to uh
support this thanks very much um yeah
i'd just add my
comment i'll bring you yeah um so i i
hear what the objector says about could
it be in other locations
um and that is very valid but of course
that's not what we're here for we're
here we can only look at the application
before us in this location and it's for
us to only decide on what's before us we
have no opportunity to look at other
sites today
um because that's not what's before us
so i will support this as well um
country uh sorry you want to come back
yeah
councilwell we wanted to come back sir
thank you
yeah
yeah i support it i think it's very good
idea in terms of visibility i think it's
an advantage to have
something fairly solid on the through on
the through line so that people do
actually slow down
it is a bad design um roundabouts are
supposed to be designed so that you have
to slow down before you go into the
roundabout on this particular design you
have to slow slow down when you're
partway round which is uh which it can
be a cause of accidents but i think
having a piece of art and having that
something that blocks the view through
is an advantage i'm fully supported i
was just a bit concerned about the um
the information board
thank you very much well it's been
proposed by council of past more than
second by councillor ebern so i'll now
hand over to the to yourself to take us
through the recommendation and for the
electronic vote
thank you chair some members the
recommendation is as in your papers
and that vote is now in progress
chair can i take your vote please thank
you
yes sorry members you will need to
scroll down to the bottom of the page
because this was
application 7c
thank you members chair that's six votes
for that's unanimous okay thank you very
much
a
uh which is
yeah we'll just move the speakers around
quickly
okay so welcome back we're now moving on
to agenda item 7a which is in the ward
of elmsworth warpit
and we'll now hand over to the case
officer who'll take us through this so
jasmine over to you
thank you chair and good morning members
i'm presenting a reserve matters
application today for the erection of 86
dwellings at land north and west of
school road elswell
the reserve matters being considered
under this application include
appearance landscaping layout and scale
members are reminded that this
presentation is solely in support of the
committee report and in no way seeks to
replace the content of that report
putting the site into context the site
is shown by the hatched area
the railway line is located to the north
of the site and
the site is north of school road and
runs down towards church road
the site joins the existing settlement
within elmsworth which is located to the
east
the outline application was presented to
members in 2020 and included
access arrangements
as per the associated section 106
agreement affordable housing highways
improvements pre-school land public open
space school contributions and upgrades
to the public right-of-way were all
secured
as per the table papers we've received
two amended responses from suffolk
county council highways and landscaping
neither quantity object to the proposal
a summary is provided on screen of their
comments
it is noted that several conditions are
recommended which are to be added to the
recommended list of conditions within
your committee report
here is the extent of the red line
boundary for the site the site joins
parnell lane along the west a public
right-of-way and railway line run to the
north
and school avenue is located to the east
the site extends southwards and includes
land adjoining school road as you can
see by that kind of long area there
in terms of constraints the built-up
area boundary of elms was shown
towards the east shown by that brown
line
several listed buildings are
located near to but outside of the site
boundaries so you've got um arms houses
which is grade two star listed to the
south west
uh there's a public right-of-way which
is footpath 14 running along the
northern boundary which is shown by the
green dashed line
the site is wholly within flood zone one
and is not vulnerable to pluvial
flooding
here we have the illustrative site plan
zoomed out and zoomed in
this was submitted as part of the
outline application and as i say is
wholly illustrative it demonstrated how
86 dwellings could materialize on the
site including public open space
sustainable urban drainage systems early
years land and landscaping
as you can then see the spine road
is entirely as per the
illustrative outline drawings
and the layout is broadly in accordance
with that as well
a permissive path is proposed along the
eastern boundary connecting to school
avenue and school road
and runs adjacent to the land set aside
for the early years provision which is
just to that north
shown by kind of the white area
an attenuation basin and swales are
incorporated and contribute to the
overall landscaping of the site
and public open space is central within
that site
in terms of story heights there will be
both bungalows and two story dwellings
incorporated into the scheme which you
can see just around you've also got
single story garages as well which are
shown between some of the dwellings
a mixture of red brick and rendered
elevations are proposed whilst a variety
of roof tiles are also proposed
these are to be agreed via condition as
requested by the council's heritage team
that is reflected in the proposed
recommendation by offices
follow the following four slides provide
some cgi images of the site
demonstrating how the variety of house
types materials scales and architectural
features will be used across the site
this image looks into the site from the
southern access point
private drives are highlighted by a
changing materials as you can see
between the
tarmac main spine road and the pink
drive
um
houses would be fronted by landscaping
before uh meeting school road along that
southern area so you can kind of see
where you've got the the fencing and
then an area of kind of
landscape buffer
this image shows the dwellings facing
onto parnell road and over the adjacent
field towards the arms houses and church
again you can see a change in surfacing
materials between the private drive and
a more secondary a more formal secondary
link road
here we have the dwellings facing again
onto pano lane and the attenuation basin
but this is at the top of the site
again there is landscaping separating
the dwellings from adjacent fields
offering a more rural edge of settlement
character
finally we have the dwellings which
would
look over the public open space in the
centre of the site these would offer a
form of natural surveillance as you can
see
the following two slides provide a
flavor of the variation materials scales
and architectural features which
will be within the street scene so
street scene a at the top
shows the dwellings facing northwards
which would then face onto the public
right of way
street scene b shows the dwellings
facing northwards towards the land set
aside for the early years um
provision in kind of the this
northern half of the site
and then street scene c shows the
dwellings around the public open space
which is similar to what was shown on
the
cgi's
street scene d at the top shows the
housing facing onto panel lane
which was shown in cgi images two and
three and then street scene e at the
bottom shows the site frontage onto
school road
in terms of the hard surfacing approach
in order to demarcate the different
areas within the site and improve
legibility the main spine road would be
tarmacked and different types of blocked
paving would be used for the link roads
and private drives
rolled hogging would be used for the
proposed permissive path along the
eastern boundary of the site which is
suitable for wheelchair push chair use
whilst there are some triple parking
plots these are all surplus to the
required parking under suffolk county
council parking guidance
these would however provide additional
parking spaces if required and are all
located off of private drives and near
to visitor spaces as well
active ev charging points are provided
to all plots with garages those without
will have ducting installed to
facilitate the installation of ev
charging at a later date
secure and covered cycle storage is
provided to each dwelling either within
the garage or sheds on plot
47 plots would have pv installed as
shown by the green dots which i'm not
sure you can really see that well um but
that's on 47 of the plots which were all
the ones in blue as well
uh pink plots which the 39 plots are to
be built under current building
regulations which is pre-june 2023 but
they offer a 19 improvement over the
existing rugs anyway
the blue plots which is the 47 are to be
built under new building roads post june
2023
there are a range of boundary treatments
proposed across the site ranging from
timber panel fencing between the gardens
close boarded fencing
to parking areas brick walls to visible
locations along the
main roads and knee rail fencing to the
site boundaries
starting from the southern access this
plan shows a variety of landscaping
around the site including wildflower
meadows amenity grass seasonal wetlands
sensory mix trees and ornamental
hedgerows
the variety of landscaping in the
southern area is then continued through
the site towards the northern area so
you can see with that attenuation basin
in the northwest corner
and place services are happy with the
proposed landscaping as per the tabled
papers
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the reserve matters as per
officer's recommendation within the
committee report and the tabled papers
thank you for listening
thank you for that could you just run
through from sorry to hog the limelight
straight off can you just run through
for me
why the why it's been built in two tiers
i mean why can't it all be done to the
maximum why is it not being all done to
the best possible standard why are we
in many ways doing it in two tiers and
why haven't all the houses have the
applicant i mean we can ask them when
they come up any reasons at this stage
um
obviously there'll be uh differences in
you know they'll have to discharge a lot
of conditions and they'll be um the
phasing the development as well but it
will
i'd suggest probably um asking the
applicant that question
and heating of the houses
uh yes sorry so that's uh to be by gas
boilers but there will be um
hydrogen converter kits provided
final question sorry triple parking my
favorite
um could you just run through how many
have truck parking where those people
are meant to park because we know what
tends to happen yes so um i can't give
you an exact number i can count them for
you uh if you want but all of the ones
that do have triple parking on um it's
all surplus to the requirement under
suffolk county council's parking
guidance
so
if they remove the garage it would still
be in accordance with the parking um and
it wouldn't then be
kind of that triple parking it would
just be the the kind of tandem parking
so we can pick that up
as
yeah
okay thank you yes cancer madison and
cancer field
yeah that the i'm
confused about this business about the
um
the preschool which inevitably although
it's not before us today
we are effectively determining where
it's going to go
and the there was the reasonable point
that
was made that the
um that
it was as far into the estate as it
could be maximizing the fact that he
never to be quite a few of the kids will
be brought in in cars
going past all the houses or as many
houses as
possible effectively um
but that this had been addressed and
changed but i i i i couldn't really
quite see where the pre preschool was
going to go on the indicative
and i wondered whether and it still
seems to be as far away from the
from school road as it could possibly be
um can you just help
understand what
changes and negotiations have or haven't
gone on there please
alicia could you get up the um the
slides for me thank you
right if i
just
scroll back
so can you see i don't know is the mouse
set up yeah there we go so this is where
the the preschool land is going as per
this application
just for reference as well if i go
back one
that was where it previously was going
and this land so as per the section 106
the land and contribution is all that is
secured under that section of analytics
obviously as you say further details of
the the overall appearance and
everything will come forward in a
separate application
secured somewhere on site
so i believe what happened in terms of
the um negotiations but you may wish to
ask
the applicant about this anyway is i
believe it had been moved somewhere to
the south here but there were concerns
about the parking and particularly a
long school road so it's then been moved
back which is
the
highway authority and
education are happy with where it is
located um additional kind of visitor
spaces have been provided around it
which i would notice is not required
but has been nonetheless provided
and there is also this path um
which would run along which obviously
connects into school avenue as i said
but would
allow kind of a walking
route to school which would also be
suitable for push chairs
yeah so it's maybe maybe the the
location has sort of changed twice and
and um but it is now back in a position
which maximizes cars going past houses
to get there
by car
um yeah okay well thank you
okay councillor field you know
thank you you mentioned um
gas boilers with hydrogen conversion
kits i just wondered
when do we imagine uh the gas grid will
be 20 hydrogen and when's it going to be
100 hydrogen
unlikely in my lifetime i guess but have
you got a figure that's you're relying
on
um so that's one question
uh second one on a slightly different
tack is there's quite a lot in page 59
about the preschool and the various
acoustic requirements
uh there doesn't seem to be anything in
the recommendations about acoustic
requirements for anywhere
could you
explain the difference between those two
things
jim could i can i just chip in so
perhaps councilwood you can direct me
because i'm looking at the version on
the website it doesn't have numbering
and which comment you're picking up on
that because i was going to say
something about preschool at this point
the
comment from
andy rushton edwards which i say on page
59 in my
baby suffolk working together
environmental protection officer there's
a whole load of things about there's
some of it's about the preschool
building which i guess
will be decided when the building is
approved but some of it seems to be
acoustic
things i'm not sure quite whether it's
to prevent the children suffering from
the railway or the
residents suffering from the children
there's some extended
comments there bringing philip on that
point more detailed than i've seen
before
so chairman without commenting on
mutually assured destruction um
the reserve matters that you have before
you do not include preschool they are
literally still within the description
of of development as uh described by the
applications so that's a piece of
housekeeping we will need to do uh
following this meeting and
uh the applicant is in agreement that
from the description of development we
remove early years because you're not
looking at the reserve matters for that
building at this point in time and
indeed they will follow on
so the design of the building the
technical comments that we have there
clearly will be relevant at that point
in time
but at the moment the application as you
have before you does not have
and should not be treated as being the
reserve matters for the early years
building because i cannot tell you what
they are and nor are they part of the
application safe for the site of it and
its location within this development
so to that extent
as a reserve matters application the
description includes early years
provision and i suspect that simply
because it follows along from the
outline but literally
early years provision are not
the reserve matters are not present here
and are not asking committee to make a
decision on them
thank you and presumably there's no
acoustic requirement to the rest of the
building
to isolate it from the railway tracker
that's not
um i would expect any of that would come
i mean it's clearly the site and the
building will need to be detailed
reserve matters for
appearance landscaping layer scale of
building for the preschool all of those
elements
will address that point
thank you
okay cancer
sorry there was a question about
hydrogen and when is it you know we're
imagining this will happen
i i think chairman planning officers are
not in a position to give you advice on
that um we would suggest you decide the
application in front of you
thank you
one final question may i have
there's a
uh
issue about the transfer of open space
to a management company
or other nominated bodies such as the
parish council
it talks about open space there's
presumably quite a bit of road
uh that will need to be transferred here
and
also um
you know it roads to the right of
brick i think the highways tend not to
adopt those
so
there's roads there's also a sun's
drainage system where it's unclear who
will be adopting that i just wondered
what the constraints on that management
company what sort of form it takes and
its ability to
raise charges to residents at subsequent
years
have some experience that they can get
excessive
i think we've all seen the situation
that's emerged with management companies
in relation to open space and other
matters
they're not part of the reserve matters
as you have before them um and i think
from memory the section 106 did include
the potential for for transfer transfer
uh locally i'd need to check further
whilst the meeting goes on to confirm
that i don't have any of the management
company details to talk to this morning
but clearly i recognize the issue
and in practical terms
uh you know they sit as an agreement uh
an element under the section 106 and as
i say i'll continue to check that and
perhaps come back to council field
during the course of the meeting thank
you
[Music]
um thanks matthew just two or three
points if i may um one thing i noticed
on page 69 um
the um second indented point there
towards the bottom
um concerning it recommends a minor
change in the alignment of this section
of the estate road
i just want to know if that had been
taken into account i know it's very
specific
it's on page 69 um this is from the
police services bloke
um
it's about traveling north along the
school road the proposed states road
between plots 80 and 81
there's page 69.
have you got that one i'm sorry it's a
bit specific but that is
i don't know whether that be
taken into account
you got the one i mean
um yes so we've had the as per your
table papers there's an additional um
updated response so there was an amended
layout that was submitted which has
addressed all of the the previously kind
of raised comments
if i may one you will not be surprised
to hear me say because i think i'll
bring this up at every meeting
um and i think it can be conditioned but
we can regarding um driveways and the
permeability so we don't end up with
hard standing driveways
as we live in such a dry part of the
country so that as we maximise the
permeable surfaces as possible
and i'd also wanted to ask if i may on
details to biodiversity
does it include things like um
swift boxes house martin cups etc
without going through a great big
shopping list i know there's lots but
can we put all those in i'm quite happy
to take it from the point of view that
that would all be looked at in general
anyway so it's the drainage not having
too much hard standing in on driveways
and just the biodiversity but please
thank you
yeah i think uh that we can you know we
could condition um certainly the
permeable surfaces with the the block
paving and i suspect they probably will
be permeable anyway
um in terms of biodiversity i'm not sure
if there was a condition um on the
outline yet so there's a condition on
the outline yep that's already been
sorted
philip you want to come back
thank you chairman yes so the section
106 for council fields benefit uh
assumes uh potential transfer to
management company or elms or parish
council or such other body as the
district council may
elect so there's a cascade mechanism set
out within the section 106 for the open
space provision
details at this stage i don't think have
been sorted out and i imagine that
there's a conversation uh to be had with
the parish council regarding the detail
of uh whether or not they wish to
uh have any role in taking the land on
uh and certainly a question whether
that might fall to district council so
not don't have the detail it's managed
within the section 106 um in relation to
the outline permission
and it doesn't necessarily uh need to be
uh
a concluded picture at this point so
we have the details such as we have i
can't provide more light on on the
issues
thank you thank you councillor welling
thank you chair um i've got a question
about the approval process for the
preschool it says in 12 2 on
28
that will be subject to scrutiny by the
parish council and by members
so
that will come before a district council
committee do the county have any role in
this
depending on who the applicant is if the
county makes an application to itself
they're in they are antiqually entitled
to rely upon the planning permission
that exists they might apply in their
own right on the land so
you could see the site come forward in
one of two ways either through the
planning authority ourselves or through
the county who would then consult us
those are both perfectly possible and we
cannot prescribe which route so no
indication one way or the other at
present
no no thank you
um
are there any proposals to assist
crossing
school road from the site
at which point chad well at uh um for
instance where the
the footpath towards the
preschool site is going
we're talking about people will be able
to use that that footpath the new
footpath to get to the preschool side
are there crossing points
um i'm only thinking of drop curves i'm
not thinking about contr you know
traffic lights or anything
uh
sorry jimin so there's there's a
footwear runs around the northern edge
of school road um
and
there's footway connection which runs
down to that
on the east side of the site within the
landscape belt there
is are you referring to
crossing the road there going south onto
the land on the other side of school
road
at any point is there are there drop
curves or any other proposals to get
from one side of school road to the
other
um i mean there are three possible
locations i just wondered if there are
drop curbs either existing or proposed
at either where the red dot is
near near the spine road
or at the other end of the site
so um
chairman there is shared cycleway
footway designed for that
highway verge
side area running all the way along so i
imagine as that will terminate the
footwear to the easton and there's
potentially a drop cut i would need to
check the drawings and
need a little time just to just to look
at that detail german but i imagine
that's part of what's anticipated
uh
but in terms of a drop curve for general
access i'm
uh i'd have to check further
thank you thank you country
one other question on the 10-year plan
the plan of ten years um
it appears that all the affordables are
well they're not they're not dotted
around the site they seem to be
mainly around the the preschool side
are you happy with that is that as
recommended
is that you know a good way forward
thank you yes so in terms of the um
affordables so you've got um i believe
there's 22 in
um
well you've got 14 in one cluster and
then i think it was about 13 or
probably a little bit more in another
one and towards the northern part of the
site like you say
having said that they are separated
there are open market dwellings in
between and kind of intervening so there
are kind of two clusters and strategic
housing um
have assessed the application and have
checked the locations of those
affordable units and they are content
with uh the approach that's been taken
and i haven't checked but how do we know
how many of those are to the highest
standard and how many to the
you know the post 2023 standard or the
the current standards
uh in terms of building regulations yeah
yeah i think they were all
pink ones i think they were pre
yeah they're to be built under the
current building regulations but
under those current building regulations
they are still offering a 19 improvement
beyond what is currently required
okay thank you
uh counselor e blah blah blah
um thank you thank you chair um i also
wanted to ask about
the same questions keith that's
counselor well but secondly the
landscaping um
along can you just confirm what
landscaping is along the railway side um
it's quite hard to see and i'm not sure
what was agreed i can't find anything
that was agreed at um outline
for that and my other question i think's
for the
um applicant thanks
thank you so i think uh in terms of the
the landscape i'm just looking at the
plan now i don't know if at least you
want to get it up i don't know if it's
going to
be able to
be very visible
and so as you can see there is kind of a
landscaped buffer and to the top i
believe it probably isn't going to be
more than kind of grassland meadowland
that sort of thing and as you can see
that there are
um
there are some kind of sporadic trees
and some some hedgerows and
if i go to scroll down
so can i come back is that a sound
buffer then or just a very simple
um
decorative buffer let's say
i think it is just a decorative buffer
but you may wish to ask that of the
applicant
councilman
thank you chair we we've very much been
looking at the the
the main built part of the site but the
red line of course includes the road all
the way down to the
church more or less
and really i've got two two questions
which um
which relate down to the that bottom end
so maybe we have a slide that shows us
that that the the first one is
regarding the the this goes back to the
outline section 106
where we did
we were particularly offered
um
to secure the possibility of the
cycle route eventually to woolpit um
going around the back of the church
effectively
and um
that's that's um
that's mentioned in 4.2 particularly
um where where the 4.2 talks about the
cycle infrastructure towards the church
um and the the parish council does feel
on page
15
um their point number four
that the that we are somehow removing
the opportunity for the community
cycle and footway to be delivered um
passing behind the church
and i i wondered
if we could just explore that a bit
carefully
because i don't definitely don't want to
do what the parish are saying
it does do
if i make the point well enough
and um yeah i'll just keep the second
one back while we look at the first one
perhaps
so in terms of the um the cycleway
footwear provision
yep
there we go
um
so the i believe that the blue line plan
under the outline included this area
kind of running as you say behind the
church
the site plan for the reserve matters
does not include that land it only runs
up to the junction with church road
so there will be some highways
improvements along this along school
road and church road
and school road leading to to church
road but it doesn't include anything
around the church and that would have to
be delivered separately
perhaps council of geek may be able to
help us i would parish is it policies
um well uh perhaps we can ask the parish
representative or the ward
representative to
to explain
how apparently um
we we are going to lose that opportunity
if we approve what we've got in front of
us so we'll come back to that one chair
the the other the other question i've
got paragraph
5.5
um
there's a discussion about um
the the works
that are required to the junction
of
school road church road
um
and and it it
it seems it's it's succeedable must be
into a chicken and egg situation where
where we need to bring this
we need to get this application approved
quickly um
in order to get the the highway works
done
but on the other hand really we want the
highway works done before
the development takes place
and um
and this all is all um
seems to be part of an argument as to
why we needed to brought this forward um
possibly before everything was um
finalized with with the consultees
um so
i don't know whether anybody can explain
um
how how this can be resolved it's as if
the county aren't prepared to
do the works unless we approve
these reserved matters but on the other
hand they're already required under the
outline aren't they bring philippine on
that point chairman shall i try and shed
light uh into a slightly confusing
situation
so when the application came before
committee in january 2021 i recall there
was quite a lot of debate around the
provision of cyclewave footway
um i'm struggling at the moment to lay
hands on the plan that's got it but i've
certainly seen a plan in relation to i
think the discharge of one of the
conditions that shows that link
potentially available but the link is
not designed and funded at this point in
time and that will rest
that will that will fall back to
sustrans county council and other body
to action
so the link at the the link at the back
of the church so um jasmine for the ease
of reference perhaps if we can get a
site plan which shows that sort of area
that will be useful
so and if you use the
so there is effectively a a
one one of the drawings on there are a
suite of discharging condition
applications and this reserve matters
application which are presently with us
um
there is intention to reserve that land
for that purpose and that has been uh
achieved but it's not being delivered by
these reserve matters because it needs
to be separately funded and delivered so
the intent is to make it happen the when
and how isn't sorted by the outline
commission here and that's
understandable because the outline
permission doesn't cause
that as a harm which must be mitigated
so that's that element of it this
application includes reserve matters
relating to the footway cycleway
connection
from
the area adjacent to the arms houses
up school road and round into the
village so they are
they are part of the reserve matters
presently before you
certainly i think there is discussion
within the community about whether
what's on the table is acceptable
i've spent some time
on site with both the applicant
and their team and with the parish
council and board member and county
councillor discussing this
and met with highway highway officers to
discuss the school road junction um
in particular terms with uh county and
uh ward members
um i don't think councillor geek was
present from memory so
there is a proposal to improve the
junction which uh i think
it is it is agreed is the most
appropriate solution in the
circumstances albeit
this is not a perfect situation but then
the present situation is not perfect at
the school road junction and then there
is the question of the cycleway footway
which is part of this is covered
governed by a number of conditions
uh in the section 106 and the planning
commission so
that's that and what you have before you
is a reserve matters application which
includes some of that detail but you've
also got comments from uh county highway
authority
the sec the timing question i think was
referred to
and in essence
part of this is about finding capacity
in the road network to be able to do the
works because it's quite a long program
of work i'm sure the applicant can
remind us because
i've been told more than once before
about how long it will take but i think
of the order of 20 or so weeks at least
is potentially the time that this road
will be subject to works happening so
that time needs to be booked with the
highway authority the section 278 has
been through stage 2 safety audit and as
i understand it in relation to the
junction cycleway has been
approved
and
the
the works then obviously need to be
booked into to deliver them
now my point to any planning committee
is that none of that pays for the works
so you know the delivery of the scheme
and the timing of that i'm sure the
applicant can speak to much better than
i
but it matters in the sense that
proceeding with the scheme enables the
funding of these works
which take us one step forward in terms
of connectivity and dealing with
uh addressing improvement to the school
road i mean there was a lot more i could
say german i'll leave it there
well that was a fine long answer for a
short question um so we'll we'll we'll
keep keep the point
and bring it and i'll ask the the parish
council what the particular concern
that's your call you have that choice to
ask the parish council anything
okay thank you so well um no other
questions
uh on that so we'll now move on we now
move on uh firstly to the parish council
and mr peter dao welcome uh you have
three minutes and over to you when
you're ready please thank you chairman
um we're very grateful for the
involvement of your chief planning
officer who has attended on two site
meetings and helped to concentrate minds
on the two issues which are most
important to the community the first of
course is the road the latest iteration
is one following many which are founded
on highways issues
i realize that you are bound by the
professionals the highways officers at
suffolk county council
who like things like
oval roundabouts but we will just brush
over there
but there's considerable disappointment
in the community about the apparent
width of school road that is on offer it
does not allow the safe passage of two
htvs
and it will simply confirm the problems
which are currently
encountered whereby people have twice in
the last three months been struck by the
wing mirrors of lorries as pedestrians
try to walk down the road
there is disappointment that the
the psychopath the community pathway is
not grade separated and physically
separated from the pavement what it
looks as though in the eyes of the
community we're getting is a slightly
wider pavement on which bicycles can
pass that is causing a lot of concern
it may be too late but i would ask
members to be aware and help us towards
a much safer result and give careful
consideration if they're minded to think
that this could be improved to go back
to highways and try to get it improved
the other issue is the preschool
facility it's on a very cramped site
um
parking is essentially
as on the indicative layout will just
about deal with the staff
um the site is at the village boundary
so the majority of people will drive to
drop their kids off remembering that
they quite often do this twice in the
day it isn't like a primary school
morning and evening it's morning
afternoon and evening in order to do
that they will either park on school
road and walk down the
uh the walkway the pavement
leaving a very dangerous situation on
school road or they'll drive through the
estate and look for somewhere to park
what is suggested
is that the indicative
layout of the site could be changed so
that the school the preschool site could
be adjacent to the green space which
would first of all allow some breathing
some what we call forest school facility
for our existing nurseries in the
village
and it could also allow some
leeway in terms of parking for
delivering and leaving
the kids at the nursery
um
parking on school road otherwise we see
is inevitable and incredibly dangerous
and if if members could address both of
those issues in depth we'd be very
grateful
thank you very much any questions at all
yep councilman yeah okay
can you can you elaborate on on your um
your fourth point
um which which is saying that um as at
0.3 the proposal effectively removes the
opportunity
for the community cycle for a to be
delivered on a path which passes behind
the church
what we're afraid of is that even though
106 allows that that land can be used
and i don't know the technicalities of
that
once having created the path which
doesn't use that very very much
preferred route once having created the
the substandard route it will be the
more difficult to um to reverse that
process and go behind the church going
behind the church
removes
two obstacles first of all you remove
the danger the serious danger of the
school or churchill junction and
secondly you remove the gradient you end
up on the same level on down bunkers
hill as you because the church is in
effect on a mound you don't have to
climb the mound and go down the mound
you go round the mound making it a much
much more desirable way
to get down to all of him
thank you
the outline discussion to put it behind
the church
what i don't understand is how this
the alignment that's proposed
in front of us
for that cycle path um
prevents it from then going behind the
church
i'm i don't build highways i would
imagine that having spent the money and
done the engineering works to to follow
the route as proposed it would be the
more difficult and the more expensive to
re-route it but hopefully i'm wrong
phillip do you want to come in on that
point i think uh if i can shed a little
more light um so
the section 106 associated with outline
anticipated a three meter wide cycleway
footway
running alongside school lane which was
shown
on what looks to be an aerial photograph
at a point um and jasmine if you can get
the plan up again
so i can kind of
guide members on this
if you
see the row houses
along church road and there's a the
boundary at the rear garden boundary of
that
yeah if you've got that up on the other
side of the road approximately that's
where a safeguarded area an additional
three metre wide cycle path
is safeguarded now in the section 106
let me just refer to a different
document
so
um
so you effectively have a
a linear route
skirting the back of the church which
then
drops down
to
join church lane
at a point i would say is approximately
20 or so meters beyond uh the
southwest boundary of the church but
that's doing this by eye of an aerial
photograph so i wouldn't want to be code
and and this is
this is an you know the note attached to
the drawing in the section 106 says it
exact alignment will depend on site
levels so there is some sorting of that
however that's just the route in terms
of the
document itself it's an obligation to
the county council not to the district
council
and that makes sense because of the
funding questions we've talked about in
the network provision um
if you bear with me chairman
i'm nearly there
yeah it's a covenant to the county
council specifically
to reserve
and not use the pedestrian cycle link
land for any purpose that would render
it unsuitable for its intended purpose
under the deed is a cycle path uh
pedestrian link
uh for a period of ten years so that
holds the position for ten years i'm not
sure how these reserve matters
compromise that
and
there's clearly a a mechanism for
transfer and
construction which is built into this
but the funding is not there so there's
a degree of ensuring the land can come
across to the county council and is held
for the time being available for the
purpose
but again i'll come back to the purpose
of this planning committee
this planning committee is considering
reserve matters
we are not considering the detail of
that they i don't believe have been
funded or
designed in a way which would allow us
to
state with certainty
where they will connect to
although as you've heard from uh
the club to also parish council clearly
there is some disappointment
um i i think i'd question his pejorative
language of substandard technical advice
we have on the proposals before you this
morning are not that they're substandard
um and that may be what you call a
difference of opinion thank you
thank you yeah thank that thank you for
that yeah i mean so i think the
essential point is is that the the
psychopath as proposed today is gonna
it's gonna drop cyclists right in front
of the arm's house beside the arms
houses
and and it would to divert behind the
arms houses and the church it would need
to divert it a little bit sooner
before it reached
the final point yet and and that
therefore
that last bit is
tending to to yeah i
think i see the point
um and we're on questions at the moment
yeah i think we can
what's the question i think now i think
the question is i think that is
sufficiently explained okay
okay
thank you
any other questions at all
at this point
nope for the
parish council no okay so we'll move on
uh so thank you for that uh we now move
on to uh
on page sorry uh so we now move on to
the
how's it going after the paper
okay now move on to the applicant alex
clark thank you um
and then we have some others who can
answer questions as needed again over to
you and three minutes please
good morning share good morning members
uh my name is alex clark and i'm the
design technical director at law homes
eastern i'm joined this morning by steve
lee as architectural technical manager
and james bailey is our planning agent
between us we should be able to answer
any questions that you may have about
our scheme at school road elmswell
as set out in the offices report the
site already benefits from an existing
outline planning consent it's in an
allocation within the emerging babur and
mid-suffolk joint local plan and it is
also identified as a site for growth
within the currently drafted elmsworld
neighborhood plan
it is therefore clear that the principle
of residential-led development on this
site has already been agreed
the reserve matters application is now
providing the detail in terms of layout
scale appearance and landscaping the
application was submitted to mid suffolk
count district council in march of this
year and it followed detailed
pre-application discussions with both
district and county council officers
ward members and elmersville parish
council
the benefits of the scheme before you
include that all the poems will meet the
nationally described space standards or
ndss with brawl homes being one of the
only few developers and builders to
offer this within mid-suffolk there will
be electric vehicle charging points for
all on-plot parking spaces with ducting
being provided where this is not
possible
the scheme is meeting the council's
emerging policy of 19 carbon reduction
alongside improved fabric efficiency
this is being achieved by proposing flue
gas heat recovery systems alongside
hydrogen conversion kits
some pvs are being provided across the
site depending on the orientation of the
plot this is the same energy strategy
that we used for our development at stow
upland and recently approved at union
road in one house
we also agreed this approach to our site
along melford in baber
as set out in the office's report at
paragraph 6.7 it's felt that these
proposed measures are reasonable and
proportionate
a site for a proposed preschool has been
discussed and agreed with suffolk county
council education department a number of
positions have been considered for the
preschool which have included extensive
discussions with officers from the
district and county the paris council
and the ward members its final location
towards the middle of the eastern
boundary is deemed acceptable by suffolk
county council in terms of its delivery
and also from a highways perspective
various highways improvements will also
sought through the on outline consent
which we are now proposing to bring
forward these include improvements to
the church road school road junction
road widening along certain parts of
school road and the delivery of a
significant proportion of the elmsworld
wool footpath and cycleway all of which
are detailed in the outline consent i am
pleased to report that the working
drawings have been technically approved
by suffolk county council an independent
row safety order has also been approved
and the legal agreements are currently
being engrossed with the necessary
licenses applied to commence the work in
august
in conclusion the proposals you see
before you this morning have been
developed through extensive discussions
with officers members elmshore parish
council and the local community there
are no objections from any of the
statutory council and broad homes are
committed to bring forward a high
quality sustainable housing scheme which
starts with positive engagement with the
local community
both myself last sentence please thank
you sir both myself and my technical
colleagues are therefore happy to commit
ourselves here this morning to being the
first points of contact with the parish
and ward members if there are any
concerns and on this basis we
respectfully request the members endorse
the officer's recommendation and approve
this application this morning thank you
sir thank you
okay questions who wants to go first
cancer even
um thank you chair if i could pick up
the building regs
point because building regs were um
changed exactly a week ago today i think
um so we've got a year of interim before
they become um permanent in june 2023 so
they're out there they're published what
and you you knew they were coming
well everybody knew they were coming so
can you can you explain why you're only
doing half the units and particularly um
you're not doing the affordables in the
new building regs and then secondly
could you um
or could i ask whether you would be
prepared to do more landscaping along
the railway side because i think that's
um
very poor landscaping there so if you
could um respond to those too thank you
very much
uh thank you caslibun um
so in terms of uh sustainability uh i
think probably about six weeks ago i sat
in front of two months ago staying in
front of this committee and we had a
20-minute discussion around you know
what we as a developer are looking to do
um
in terms of in terms of building rigs
you're absolutely right
in 20 in 2023 it's all based around when
the foundations that particular plot go
in so on this site we've anticipated
when that's likely to be um we're
meeting your emerging policy of 19
across the board
and from that point in time of june 23
when the foundations of those plots go
in they'll meet building regulations
which is
what we're committed to doing
but you're not really answering the
question why are the affordables in the
first round and not getting the higher
quality home
um i believe some of the affordables are
in the top
middle middle section so it's not all of
them aren't um it's purely based around
build root and how we would build that
that site and in actual fact you could
look at it in a positive way that we're
looking to deliver those those units
first
yeah you can spin anything uh you could
also argue the opposite uh so why is the
whole site could you just explain why
aren't you just doing the whole site to
the highest standard i mean why not just
do it so there's no difference between
half the estate why not just do it all
to the better standard
because building rigs dictates um
that
well the energy the energy policy that
this council has emerging policy is 19
which we're meeting so we're in excess
of this council's existing policy we're
meeting the emerging policy and we'll
also be meeting building regulations i
get all that but we do have other
developers who come here who go way
above the current guidelines and say
we're going above that but what you're
saying is you're going to do the minimum
but 19 more so you're not going to do so
you're doing it in two phases and that's
set in stone
we'll we'll meet building rakes at the
time of those foundations
can we just talk about gas boilers and
the hydrogen question that council of
fields has brought up earlier
yeah so as i said
we sat here a couple of months ago and
had quite a detailed discussion about
this
we
are going to be predominantly gas on on
this site it'll be with gas
boilers we'll provide hydrogen
conversion kits we're in discussions
with the likes of gtc and cadence and
they are currently upgrading their
network at the minutes they believe that
there's going to be again a phased input
of hydrogen as in terms of when a blend
will come in and they've set
targets for when that's likely to be um
i don't have those in front of me but i
think 2030 was when there was so in
effect since you last came to the
committee law homes has not progressed
moving to air source heat pumps like
other developers you're still going to
go with gas for as long as you can and
that's the principle is it on this
particular development that is what our
proposal is okay thank you
um thank you chair could you respond
about the landscaping along the railway
actually sure sure thank you very much
for your question um so it's a soft
landscape buffer across that that
section so there is some i think there's
hedge planting across there um there is
a an existing chain link fence which
separates the
network rail land from the the site and
we're looking to landscape in front of
that so you wouldn't put
more of a sound barrier and a deeper
would you put a deeper landscaping to to
be more of a kind of sound barrier for
so we've because obviously all the
container trains come from felixstowe at
all hours um with hundreds and hundreds
of containers on and that's not quite so
would you put a more of a sound barrier
type landscaping along the railway side
so what thank you thank you again for
your question what we've done as part of
that
um the site is we've done acoustic
report which i think was submitted as
part of this application that identified
that with the houses as the orientation
that they are front front on the private
gardens behind those would drop below
the 55 db
mark which is which is the accepted mark
we would be looking to have additional
ventilation within those rooms at the
front um but again that's that's all
detailed within the the report so there
is because of the orientation of the
houses fronting onto that railway line
that provides um some blockage to the
houses behind of that so that has been
considered in the design of the
orientation of the plots
that's the past
um thank you matthew i'm going to ask
the same question but in a different way
to see if we can extract a proper answer
um
i'm seriously i mean math is absolutely
right we do get other developers they
really do enhance their environmental
credentials and we that's really what we
all want to do
um here in mid-suffolk so would you be
prepared to look at the um application
and revise upwards the proportion of
housing that meets the latest
regulations building regulations that
have been announced i think other
developers might i don't know whether we
have the power to do that or not as a
committee um so that's another dimension
on that and i do take the point um
regarding the um sound insulation and
the landscaping along the railway line
there again i don't know whether
there are possibilities of looking to
condition it because we do have problems
in other other areas regarding noise and
so on and we are talking about people's
quality of life here and i am absolutely
sure a reputable company like law homes
would want to do everything possible to
make sure that the these issues are
addressed and i don't know whether other
members of the committee but if
i were to propose for example acceptance
that would certainly be something we'd
like to look at and see if we could
condition it but the principle is that
we'd obviously much rather our officers
could work with you to come to a
mutually acceptable solution so there's
about 15 questions all in one some for
you and some for the planning what we're
looking for is a compromise and common
sense to prevail rather than an
entrenched view thank you
thank you thank you for your questions
and comments there um if i take your
second point first because that's that's
probably easier to to to
discuss um
we would be content to have a
a post survey condition put on there so
again we can prove um what are the
proposals worth in terms of acoustics so
we can do
some testing i'm sure phil can
agree some wording upon that that's
absolutely fine
um
something that we we have done um which
again we've i've talked about with
members in in the room is we've offered
um the option of additional pv to those
that don't have it as a sales extra and
that that would be something that we
would
we could offer sat here so people then
have have the choice um and again we've
done that successfully at other
developments so
on on that basis that's what i could sit
here and commit to today that we could
we could offer that as an extra so
people have the choice if they want to
do that then that's what they could do
okay council field did you want to come
in
yes please
oh yes um just some clarity
solar voltaic cells i was about to ask
you it says
it's proposed that solar volatile cells
on the roofs of housing to be genera to
generate electricity will be offered
on all open market dwellings
that seems to
there seems to be some contrast there
between what you've just said what and
what we've discussed earlier in the
meeting
my prime concern about conversion kits
to enable them to burn hydrogen
now allow gas boilers to burn hydrogen i
think you've just made that clear
haven't you you're saying 20 30 so we
keep the kits for eight years
and that presumably then moves us to 20
hydrogen or does that is that the date
of which we move to
100 percent hydrogen
coming out because it says couple of
things
and
to think just about the building
regulations you're talking about 19 up
left in our emerging plan which is not
yet approved
um and the new the building regulations
which are
in
been enacted now for enforcement in 2023
i guess they require a 30 uplift
and the new home standard which is two
years later requires a 70 uplift
so you don't seem to be offering very
much there you're you're
you're suggesting that you'll have the
foundations for a lot of these houses in
before 2023 which
i think's in about six months time isn't
it i'm not sure
did you make that clear
and the issue about acoustics again the
report says
attention is drawn to the need for
additional measures to protect with
residential amenities
of
future occupiers of certain dwellings
and a condition is suggested to ensure
additional noise
insulation and window specification
would provide those dwellings i couldn't
see anything in the report that says
which dwellings that applies to so is
that
is that a statement of truth and is
which dwellings will that apply to
thank you i think that's the three
issues
thank you sir
um
so if i start with the the first the
first point about the conversations
we've had with gtc and caden and and the
hydrogen point um
again we we're very much reliant upon
them and they have set 2030 as a
a blended target point because we're not
in charge of that we're just going on
what we're being told told by them but
they are making uh vast strides and if
if as i know you're particularly
interested in that i would look at the
the work that they've done up in durham
gtc and what they've done over
um in other parts of the country where
they are now running 100 hydrogen
test
developments
um
in terms of the the acoustics again
we've had a
full
noise report carried out which has
specified the
type of ventilation needed for both
purge and for trickle ventilation and
also the window specifications for those
and that was i think submitted as part
of the application but as you might say
i think it's likely to be a condition
within there that we would resubmit that
um the houses that that report
identifies are the ones that are pretty
much adjacent to the railway line uh and
probably i think it's like two or three
houses that comes off north to south on
that first road that comes through
so
so that is identified it is scoped
and that will be subject to a discharge
of condition application
and then the what was the third point
sir sorry
yeah sorry and then sustainability um
in terms of
the submission that we've made in the
energy report um is as per the officers
slide they've shown that is what we will
be offering as
pv but has already identified we would
be happy to commit here today to
offering that as a sales extra so
everybody would have the opportunity to
to be able to do to provide those
and the amount of pv that is offered on
the houses that were identified in the
offices report is what
one panel per or no no so
again i don't have the report in front
of me but it would be something circular
like a one kilowatt system per per
household
that's how i don't i don't have that so
that's about the point for me 400 pounds
worth of panels per hour okay thank you
if
can i just check in my briefing
chairman's briefing i was actually told
you'd already made that offer of
offering solar panels to all the houses
that wasn't something you're offering
new today that was already i was told
you'd made that was already existing
is that correct i mean that was already
pre-planned you had that in the system
already you were going to offer solar to
all the other houses that didn't have it
included um no i don't i don't believe
we've made that offer before but if it
is in the papers then i i apologize sir
because it's unknown to me but that's
something that we would look to do thank
you
chairman can i just pop in on this small
point is is the point that they're the
the offer is that they're being offered
but they come at a cost i suspect that's
i that's certainly my understanding of
the situation here as an add-on i think
as was described
and and just for clarity um there's a
condition on the outline planning
commission and bearing in mind we're
dealing with reserve matters application
here
there's a condition in relation to uh
sustainability
uh and as far as i can see from
the file on this we have advice from uh
environmental health colleagues and that
they are
satisfied with the submission provided
so
um
from their perspective condition 21 i
think of the outline permission has been
um satisfied
um and i appreciate all the other points
in discussion but just thought it's
worthwhile clarifying that's obviously a
condition and there is an application to
discharge that condition which has not
yet been determined but that's not in
front of the committee this is a reserve
matters application as we have it and
clearly it's relevant to consider the
total scheme i understand that um
but as i understand the internal advice
that officers have is that um the
proposal is acceptable thank you jim
thank you very much we're going to move
on to the ward members now you've got
another question for the applicant
um
sorry yeah can we have a couple great
please
yeah i've got actually two more
questions through the outcome very brief
then take that comfortably is that all
right can you just talk about how many
triple parking there are and will the
estate be adopted
by highways bearing in mind some of it
is brick on road which they don't like
to adopt could you just pick up those
two points yeah um absolutely just bear
with me two
seconds
okay so there are
on on site there are no areas with three
allocations
there are no areas with three allocated
parking spaces in front of each other
there are 12 incidents of tandem parking
followed by a garage however the garages
do not count towards the allocated
parking provision and instead intended
for cycle storage so there are no
true
triple tandem parking spaces just the 12
we have the garage behind it which don't
count as the car park space
so
yeah but a garage is for a car
but it's it's over over over provision
if you like the garage space being an
additional space okay and the road um in
terms of the road we would be looking to
have the main spine road adopted
and then have
areas of the shared drives etcetera
under under a management company thank
you
okay what we'll do is we'll take a quick
10 minute break we'll come back 25 to 12
by these clocks
yes sir
if i can chair um a question for
yourself which is a bit strange would it
be helpful to explain
the location of the preschool i was
aware that it was discussed uh in your
questions earlier it would that be
helpful for for members if not i
apologize but it i i can offer perhaps
some insights that if it would be useful
jay i i had as much of going as anybody
on that i think the
if we've reached a point where the
county which is both the educational
authority and the highways authority
are yeah i think this is the least worst
one then we i'm not sure we can explore
it any further i think it's in the
papers before us has been
the county's made its view so
thank you for that okay we'll take a
quick 10 minute break thank you
okay so welcome back everyone
um so we're to move on
now
[Applause]
continue on obviously with the same
application item 7a school road in
elmswell
unless we had any other questions i
think we'd exhausted the questions to
the applicant we're now going to move on
to the ward members we have two ward
members councillor geek and councillor
mansell uh councilmancer can't be here
today and councillor geek is going to
read out cancer mansell's
response as well as i'm sure give your
own so over to you
thank you chair um this is the statement
from councillor mansell she says she's
sorry to that she's unable to attend the
committee today but she's got a meeting
that she's unable to move
this site has a long planning history
and we're here today to discuss the
reserve matters application for 86 homes
whatever we think about the suitability
of this site for housing that is now
behind us as the principle of
development has already been established
with the granting of outline planning
permission
alongside that planning permission there
was a legal agreement and some
conditions relating to the provision of
a shared use path parallel to school
road from the existing settlement
boundary to the arms houses this shared
use path will form part but only part of
that long-awaited community path between
elmsville and woolpit as more and more
development comes to both villages the
need for this path to be completed is
becoming more and more pressing there
are still too many uncertainties about
how this path will negotiate the
roundabout and cross the a14
while we welcome this section of path
beside school road it is not at all what
our residents expected sus transport a
strip of land along this length of road
over 20 years ago for a cycle way and
although this is currently just a field
edge it provides a pleasant off-road
footpath high up from the road
the new shared use path is not going to
go up on this bank but on the same level
as the existing narrow pavement
the width of school road is insufficient
for two large vehicles to pass and hgvs
regularly mount the kerb in order to
pass each other pedestrians have been
knocked by wing mirrors and this is just
an accident waiting to happen
this new path will of course be much
wider than the existing pavement but as
it is not up on the bank users of the
path will not feel safe there is enough
land to enable this new path to be great
separated from the road and we should be
taking this opportunity to do this at
this time we should not be satisfied
with second best
it is good that law homes have been
engaging well with the community
sarah says she does not recall ever
saying that we did not want a play area
on site i'll i'll come on to that later
um
and she says there are a number of
pleasing aspects to this development
many of the houses are orientated to
make best use of solar pv and solar gain
the fabric first method of construction
is welcome
bungalows along the eastern edge
conserve the immunity of the neighbors
along school avenue all homes meet nds
space standards and all market dwellings
have the offer of solar pv
that being said there are also a number
of things that could make this
development more acceptable
ev charging infrastructure for all
dwellings regardless of whether they
have an on-plot parking space or not in
fact it's those dwellings whose parking
area is not adjacent to their property
who will find it more difficult and
costly to fit subsequently and they
don't have the option of using what i
gather is known as a granny cable either
and avoiding the use of gas boilers for
all the dwellings would also make it
more acceptable
then finally there is a position of the
preschool
and sarah says she's not sure what the
best option is the outline approval
indicative plan showed the land for the
preschool adjacent to school road then
it moved to the back of the development
and now it's somewhere in the middle
until the general population take the
desired modal shift in the way they
decide to travel wherever the preschool
is it will cause highways issues
if parents drive their children to the
preschool then they will try to park as
close to where they need to go as they
can on pavements on verges blocking
access the answer is not to provide more
parking to accommodate them
but we do need to ensure that they do
not choose to park on school road near
the new junction and the bend
so that is councillor mansell's uh
statement
i would like to echo and support the
views of mr dow from the parish council
and our councilor mansell and add a few
points firstly the play area we have
indeed said in the past that we don't
like spreading small amounts of play
equipment thinly around our villages and
we'd rather invest in better provision
in fewer places but this is a place that
could really benefit from play equipment
it's too far from the nearest other
provision and that involves going along
busy roads and there are obvious
advantages in having play equipment near
to the preschool so i i would like to
take uh bloorheims up on their um their
uh
their offer of having it included
secondly the sighting of the preschool
councilor mansell is right there is no
best place for the preschool to be in
order to discourage parking on on school
road or around the new estate where it's
currently proposed seems has seemed to
me as good as any other place although i
am also persuaded by mr dow's arguments
for having it next to the public open
space hopefully including the play area
thirdly the affordable housing um as far
as i can see in the committee report
page 119 they are all in one place they
are not interspersed with other um
with with um
with market housing could they please be
spread around a bit more
and then finally i'd like to come on to
transport let's start with buses um i'm
surprised that there are nine bus stops
within a 10-minute walk which it says in
paragraph
4.2 page 23
we wonder whether school bus stops are
being included in this list and anyway
of course none of these bus stops are
any use without an adequate public bus
service and allensville's bus service
can't be described as adequate at
present
footpaths it's great that the footpath
beside the railway is going to be
improved it's lovely that it will link
to the permissive path to the east
and finally uh to come onto the longer
cycle and footpath link between
elmsville and woolpit uh councillor
mansell and mr dao have summarized the
problems very well um i'd like to add
that the um
and we've also had a lot of chat about
it but i'd like to emphasize that the
red line area on slide six does appear
to show plenty of room for a grade
separated path
as councilor mansell points out that's
what's expected locally it's something
that feels like an improved safer
replacement to the edge of the field
path not not the pavement but to the
edge of the field path that's informally
used as pres at present
as mr dao said it's needed in order to
make that new path not only feel but
also be safe to cyclists excuse me and
walkers and indeed to everyone using it
some of these cyclists and walkers are
expected to be primary school children
having to make their way from elmswell
to a new school in woolpit so we'll
potentially have groups of nervous
cyclists and walkers who have to be
discouraged from from from stopping
using it and getting back into their
cars we have to to encourage those
nervous cyclists to stay with the cycle
path
so police could you regard this as the
absolute minimum that the residents of
elmson will pit need um as mr dao argued
for the cycle path further down um the
hill once a path has been designed
designed engineered and built it's hard
to improve if we don't get that good
cycle path a long school road first time
we are likely never to get it
in addition uh obviously it's clearly
essential that we have the ability to
run the footpath further down behind the
arms houses of the church to the north
of the church without that it's very
hard to see how that path will ever
actually be usable to get all the way to
wolpid
and i wonder if if mr isbell could
clarify exactly what the committee is
deciding today about the psychopath
would approving this application today
mean that the proposed layout of the
foot and cycle path
a long school road is set in stone and
can't be improved now given that the
reserve matters are for appearance
layout lands
landscape and scale and we have a
separate discharge of conditions
application for the highways and the
cycleway improvement
is there a role for that discharge of
conditions application to play and
ensuring that we get that absolutely
essential usable safe and trustworthy
foot and cycle path thank you
thank you do you want to just come in on
the points that's been raised
[Music]
uh thank you chairman so
this is a reserve matters application
and within
the description the uh
road winding and cycle footwear link are
mentioned
the
details of that provided here are
consistent with the section 106
provision and
what i understand was expected uh in
relation to the outline commission
i have heard from councillor mancella
and
uh well and and from county councillor
uh mellon and really and and indeed um
uh mr dao in relation to this question
of the sighting of the
footway cycleway i don't see reference
to that as an instruction for committee
from committee in the january 21
minutes
uh the comments of the parish council
previously focused particularly on the
improvement question around the junction
with school road
and there is there are references there
to safety of pedestrians and cyclists
throughout i don't see a particular
identification of an issue relating to
the position of the footwear cycleway
such that it should be in any particular
relationship to the road other than that
there should be that provision
and i don't see a particular clarity
about that
within the section 106
so throughout all that may have been in
the minds of some people
i don't
see it necessarily as being in the minds
of committee when it made that decision
i have nothing to tell me that
it's
also the case that uh those works are
the subject of a discharge of conditions
request
and there is a section 106
provision related to the junction
highway improvement works too
but i also see comments from highway uh
from the highway authority on both the
discharge of condition application that
we have which indicates that what is
before us
and not not here today i should say but
what has been provided in relation to
discharge of condition is acceptable and
in relation to this application
i understand that to be acceptable too
so what you have as far as i can see is
a difference of opinion
relating to the adequacy of what is
proposed
and without laboring the point about
decide the application in front of you
there will always be situations where
one could come up with a better scheme
arguably
we are in a situation having something
that is acceptable
and the council's role as planning
authority is to decide the question in
front of him in front of itself
as to what is or is not acceptable on
the balance of probability and as far as
i can see
the technical advice i have related to
the footway cycleway is that it is
acceptable
there is a provision in the section 106
that safeguards the long-term position
related to
the ongoing provision of that footway
cycleway
and in any event this is a development
of 86 dwellings
what councillor geek council mansell and
others are referring to appears to be a
larger piece of infrastructure related
to
the
circumstance in the village and
doubtless this as it is would provide
something but
the planning process is supposed to
mitigate harm
and
from our perspective as officers that's
what this application does at the
present point in time it does not in any
way preclude a further revised scheme
coming forward to provide a cycleway
footpath i don't necessarily agree that
um once this is delivered it is the only
answer from my perspective if there is a
better provision that might subsequently
come forward then that that may be the
case
that is a question of funding and as
this scheme is expected to fund the
delivery of those works then clearly
what we ask for must be proportionate
thank you chairman
okay thank you
any other questions to the world members
yes cancer even
um thank you chair i think this is for
the officers really the the reference to
the children's play area so in 6.5 it
said um
that
it was omitted but that um the applicant
said there have to have a condition and
in fact we've got a condition saying
details of play space
um so will that cover the
if there's already a condition saying
details of play space including
equipment specification that will cover
what the ward members are
um asking for
as in to have the player equipment put
back in again
yes as far as i'm aware and it might be
something that you want to kind of
direct towards the the applicant as well
and just to get their kind of
perspective on it but yeah as far as i'm
aware in terms of the condition that
would secure that
um thank you for that and and also chair
may i ask
is it possible just with these issues
around this footpath is it or maybe it's
for the planning of not sure whether
that we can have an informative um about
working to improve the link for the
cycle and footpath
of some sort just to kind of not so that
so this application doesn't mean it's
the end of it
i i think that's entirely appropriate i
think i mean the design of the footwear
cycleway works have been through
a part and parcel of the section 278
agreement that's been already
through with county council i think with
this decision you're perfectly limited
to do that so that you don't prejudice
and make sure that everybody is sighted
on the potential to keep the door open
for future improvements
um and this is not the only site in
elsewhere and the district council has
other land in elms or which may well
come forward which may well alter the
dynamics of how people might move
through the area so all of these things
are
you know there is a a perfectly good
reason to have an informative chairman
okay any other questions for the ward
member council madison
yeah um
so
can i be i mean this is deeply
frustrating i think it's a question for
for philip was first as well it's deeply
frustrating that we can't see
the design
um i mean can we can we not
i mean i think this is this week this is
where we we ask for the reserve matters
and the section 106 um
condition discharge
that's related to it the
the cycle path so you know it's both
come forward together so it's deeply
frustrating we haven't actually got it
in front of us as well
to see what we're talking about and i i
now understand i'm really sorry but what
is the question well the the question
the question is is
where what is the land that was bought
20 years ago by the the then
county councillor you know what is is
that land is that a different strip of
land to what's actually being put
forward in front of us at the moment as
the cycle path beside the
besides school road thank you phillip
so um jasmine i don't know if we've got
any plans in the presentation we could
turn to
uh
the the outline permission you you will
have seen
just if you go back to the outline
right so
so you can see there's a long limb of
redline that runs down school road so
that's
that's as far as i understand in
relation to this application that was
land that was considered
potentially available for that purpose i
don't know whether that is the land that
was transferred and obtained by sustrans
i don't have that knowledge here today
however sustrans are a party to the
section 106 associated with this and
clearly it was in everybody's minds at
the time section 106 was entered into to
provide an onwards link at the back of
the church and the arms houses
the scheme designed for this footway
cycleway work jasmine i don't know if
we've got anything in the presentation
we can pick that up
is
so so there's there are three drawings
these these there are three drawings
which relate to the
section 278 works and they describe both
works to the junction and the cycleway
footwear
now you'll see
two thirds of the way up that drawing
there is an oak tree and therefore the
footway cycleway skirts around that in
order to avoid harming the tree it then
returns to the side of the carriageway
and continues southwards and to the
north it obviously arrives out and
crosses part i think it's parnell lane
is the right-of-way going off to the
farm to the other side the railway line
there
but in essence you have a a proposal
that is located
uh at the at the carriageway edge for uh
what is a already a narrow uh footwear
as you may be aware
and i think this is the the conversation
that's been going on
um
have we got any better detail than that
jasmine
thank you
yeah so
in essence you've got
areas which are shown to the left of the
blue which are the
footway cycleway i think it's a three
meter wide
distance from uh what i can recall
and obviously the purple line that you
can see
purple pectin line coming in at the back
of the arms houses
is the connection point
as far as we know it at this stage
um so so those are the that that's as
much detail as we are sitting on in
relation to
uh
the scheme at the moment and the
question then is
how much land is reserved and there is
more land reserved for it
but we're dealing with the scheme before
us today not some other proposal thank
you
thank you very much i think that's
helpful
okay members so it's now up to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
on this
councillor madison
well i i i'll
you know i think i'll go straight on to
the to the you know what's been
coming out in the last few minutes and i
think we haven't got
and understand a section through so we
can see
the the different heights of this of the
road and and the land and where where
the cycle path is is
is to go
um and and i think if you couple that up
with with what mr dao said about the the
the the width of the road and the two
hgvs
and the the you you finish up with a
situation where the path
the path that is proposed at the same
level as the road is actually going to
be the the overflow
of of when two hgvs can't get past one
another and that raises a big a big red
flag in terms of of the danger of what's
being proposed so that that worries me
now very very much and it's probably not
worth declaring but i was actually a
member of elmsworth parish council when
that land was originally bought
by sustrans
by the county council and um i don't
think that's worth actually recording is
it
but uh
it's it's it does bring an extra factor
into my concern and interest in this
particular scheme getting done right
just so we need to pick that up
okay because you've just you so
can we just have clarity on that because
obviously you've been involved talking
about an area that you've been very
passionate about for the last 15 minutes
so ian can we have your comments please
can i i i'm switched on now i mean all
experienced members of this committee
know that
the rules they've had in their training
about pre-determination and bias i'm
sure councillor mathson or any other
member would
would be honest about that if it were
the case i
just
back it back to you
as it were it's for you to decide really
well give it some thoughts counselor
ebony next
um thank you chair i think um
you know
one of the the good things about this
application is there's been a lot of
discussion with the
local community with the parish council
with the ward members and so on and in
order to try to bring
um you know the best that that
they can do here today
and at the moment though
there's several issues that i think fall
slightly short one one of them is the
building legs issue which i think is
very disappointing um given that that
you know any major house builder i feel
should be really
um
looking to the building regs that are
currently in um
in the legislation as a last wednesday
and um you know ensuring that we can get
the best they can get the best possible
for the residents that are going to be
living in their their development
um
i also feel that this is
that this site we're a little bit
hostage really to hop the highways work
i mean this has come forward quite
quickly relative to the outline
application being um agreed and
you know it seems that we that you know
in order to get the highways work done
it's being kind of slightly pushed
through but that might be just a
perception that i've got
but i there is a concern about um
you know i appreciate that this was
sorted at outline permission but that
road going around the corner school road
i mean the times when i have been on it
and driving and cut and vehicles come at
you in the middle of the road coming the
other way um it's rather unnerving to
put it mildly and you do know
pedestrians jumping from the
path into the field
and so i think to that point we should
be doing everything we can
to ensure that the foot and cycle way
from that development to other
connection points
either in the village or to adjacent
villages is undertaken and we really
need to push hard to get that to happen
so i think any help from officers on
that front and i appreciate the help
officers have been giving already to
this application um should be done
so i think um you know chair got a few
concerns the the building regs the
cycleway connection and the preschool i
think that's going to turn into um
cedars primary school and nobody in that
development is going to leave or enter
that um their home or their that site in
um between the hours when the preschool
starts and finishes because it's just
going to be a nightmare for parking but
preschool is not what we're discussing
today so
hopefully
some solution will be found there
so i'm up on the fence at the moment
chair but happy to hear what other
members say thank you
cancer
uh thank you matthew well um having
listened very carefully to we've had
some pretty long discussions questions
and everything else so and i might need
some help from other members here and so
i'm actually going to propose
approval but with them various
additional conditions
informative advisory notes etc and that
is done
in the spirit of cooperation that
hopefully common sense will prevail
what we don't want to do is end up with
an antagonistic approach here and i and
i say that because obviously that
um peter dow from ellsworth parish
council did make comments i think at the
beginning he was very pleased with the
engagement the officers and so on um to
get to this stage but
um i think we're all really concerned
regarding the building regulations and
don't still don't really understand why
it can't be
um
that actually we could be looking at the
new regulations and using that more
extensively so if we have an advisory
note which is done in the spirit of
progress and cooperation and common
sense
um an informative advisory note seeing
what can be done what more can be done
to adopt the um latest regulations that
have come out and the same applies of
course to the um the cycleway and the
footpath that we've had extensive
discussions about i do really really
hope we can find a solution and i think
phillip said earlier
you have a scheme but there is always
room for improvement that's not to say
it is
a cast iron guarantee it's the perfect
solution well again i think following
discussions that everybody's had and
with ward members and so on i think
there is a way forward on that but it's
got to be the ability and willingness of
them the applicant and others to work
with people to put that forward
i mentioned earlier that seems about two
hours ago um the condition regarding the
permeability of driveways and hard
standing throughout the whole
development so i would like that put in
and again i don't want to be over
prescriptive common sense has to prevail
but i think we all know we live in the
driest part of the country and therefore
we do need to look after our aquifers
and not stick it all into some gully and
chuck it out into the river and then
into the sea because um that's really
really important in this part of the
country country um
in particular
and of course the note in there i think
was it at 6.5 regarding play equipment i
think definitely include that i think
we'd all like to see that
um so i am um obviously looking for a
second but i'm also more than happy to
add other things to that in order to
move this debate forward sharon so there
we are thank you can i just ask um
philip around the
two-tier housing that's being put on
this site one pre building roads one
outside of building roads is there
anything we can do on that to so that we
have a quality across the whole site
rather than two-tier housing
chairman i understand that situation
arises from the
sequence of build-outs and obviously
it's it's a cost item as well so
there's a there's a timing and cost
question related to it
um
i tend not to like to walk out of
committee with uncertainty about what
we're trying to achieve with an
applicant
one option you have here is to
um you know adjourn for five minutes to
see whether there is any scope for the
uh for a discussion with the applicant
about the content of that
but don't forget this is an application
for reserve matters chairman condition
21 is a separate condition
which you know from from our perspective
as officers you have advice on so
uh i think you know the reality with all
of these sites across the district is
everybody is is in a position where
there is
there's a moving picture with
what's available
um you do have the ability to as a
committee instruct me to do something
i'd always look for a bit of certainty
and it would be useful to have had the
opportunity to explore that with an
applicant before advising you further so
my own advice would be if you do want to
go down that route uh i'd ask for an
adjournment for five minutes just to
talk through the possibilities with the
applicant and to see where that stands
because ultimately that's not a reserve
matter here
that's um a detail elsewhere
i mean thank you for that i mean we we
have deferred applications in the past
when we when we've been in positions
where we where we've been up against uh
similar
a i can't remember the name of the
applicant from it was down in just on
the edge of the a14
anyway but we don't need what you're
saying is my view would be it's worth
deferring it's worth
giving philip five minutes talk to the
applicant and see if we can move
anything forward if other members are
happy with that
should we just run through the other
points first and just check there isn't
anything else i'm missing that we might
want to throw into that discussion uh
council field you were next
yes i i think there are two
two issues here
that i'm really unhappy about and which
deferment could be a solution perhaps
one of them we're just talking about the
the building regulations the the issue
that uh
it seems contrived to try and put
half the foundations in before we get a
change in
the
building standards that are required um
whether one's actually going to get that
number of houses
the foundations put in
before june next year and we are talking
about just june next year as the country
heads into recession
i would have some doubts but
nevertheless
looking for some certainty that all
these houses would be built to the same
standard
we have had some movement on on
solar pv which
seems to me sensible
but the second major issue is this one
of the footpaths
of the cycleway
it
there's some areas of uncertainty there
and i just cannot see why there's areas
of uncertainty surely to god we know
which land south strands owns
we
could
make some engineering judgments some
cost judgments about
putting the
the the footway with the suck away on
that land rather than where it is
currently proposed
clearly the northern portion of it at
the moment is sensibly space from the
road but point down the main length of
the school road is not
and it just seems impossible to me that
we're in a position that we cannot sort
out those sort of
quite minor problems we can put in uh
advisory notes
uh but you know they're pearly advisory
and and the council parsons talked about
common sense prevailing
uh yeah i agree with him but common
sense does not seem to prevail so
personally i'm profoundly unhappy with
going ahead as this is at the moment
okay thank you and just a couple more
speakers then we'll adjourn for five
minutes so philip can have those
discussions
counselor matheson
thank you yeah yeah first or something
what i'm suffering from is not not
it's it's frustration really
the the
when when we started a couple of years
ago arguing
um that that we wanted um
we wanted the discharges and some of the
conditions to come forward concurrently
that was the new word of the day then
concurrently um i
i mistakenly assumed that that would
mean that we would be able to see
what the what the
proposals were to discharge the
condition
uh when we were discussing the main
event i.e now
um and and here we are not in that in
that position and um
i mean i think the
you know it's it's a broader point than
just just the um
the the land ownership it's also the the
as i said the height differential
uh that the council of geek has referred
to and and i think that's an additional
frustration that we really ought to see
what is proposed
and indeed what could be
the case um
instead of what's in front of us um
on a future occasion as mysteries but
was said
thank you and councilwoman did you want
to add anything before we adjourn for
five minutes no so we'll adjourn just
for five minutes um i suggest we don't
if we can stay here but just give philip
five minutes to talk to the applicant
chairman can i just clarify what i'm
what i'm doing here so let me just take
you back to the cycle by footway
so the scheme as is and jasmine as as as
you showed uh on the slides
has been through safety audit and was
part of the section 106 so what the
applicant has provided there
was what officers went away and secured
in consultation with county highway
authority following the committee minute
committee minute does not talk about a
separated cycleway footwear
talks away talks about cycleway footway
and the application site you had an
outline you you had that that that broad
area
what was
uh what was put forward and what was
acceptable and what is acceptable to
county highway authority
was uh a
a footway cycleway with i think raised
kerbing to the uh
side of the carriageway
um
this conversation was part of the
discussion that was had on site the
technical advice you have before you as
a committee is that what is before you
is acceptable sorry i'm going to go back
to the question which i i usually say
answer the question in front of you is
the scheme acceptable it's not is there
a better scheme out there
is is the scheme in front of you on the
balance of probability acceptable that's
the question the planning authority
should be putting to itself when it
looks at things like this there will
always be situations where one could
design a better scheme
the applicants for their part have
designed a scheme which follows the
outline planning permission in the
section 106. so what you have before you
today does not surprise me because
that's kind of where i was expecting it
to be
what i'm sensing about what was expected
locally
does not form part of the committee
minute that i've read and you know to
that extent what am i what am i seeking
to secure in having a conversation with
the applicant is my problem here i can
talk to the app about building sides of
things but the building rigs i think is
the side you're talking about the rest
is not up for discussion it's what
because it is what's before us and and
as you've just very eloquently explained
so you know that's not for us for to
discuss now because this has come out of
a previous
meeting and what was requested so five
minutes bruce
okay so welcome back thank you for the
adjournment just to give the opportunity
for philip isabel to talk to the
applicant and do you want to report back
please
thank you chairman yes so a number of
points came out of councillor passmore's
uh
comments and requests and from
councilman and and others regarding the
um
the scheme before you today um i think
it's fair to say we are uh trespassing
on matters that are subject to
conditions but i think in the
circumstances this is about the totality
of the scheme you're interested in
can i take this in reverse order please
chairman and and start off with the
cycleway footwear because when i left
the room before that i did say the
cycleway footwear with the detail was
set out in the outline
it's
described
within the section 106.
there is no scope i believe to negotiate
a revised location of that to the top of
the bank i don't think that's got
anywhere for me to take as a matter you
know the
the reserve matters you have for that as
far as they sit within what's proposed
are
as i often say what they are um
and they are acceptable to the highway
authority i realize that other people
think differently
i have no engineering advice and the
whole scheme has been looked at by to be
honest uh highway engineers county
council independent highway engineers
doing a safety audit of it the
applicant's own highway engineers there
have been a lot of
a lot of professional time spent on that
improvement and cycleway
arrangement
i i i think from my perspective we as
officers recommend it in its present
format and i'll leave that matter there
so then coming to the other matters
cat's password talked about permeability
um as i understand it there
is a scheme
for sustainable range which is sitting
with has been commented on by the flood
authority who are very happy with what's
presently put forward
um there is a question of ground
conditions and the ability of the ground
to actually accept flows but subject
they're subject to a condition that
allows us to
manage manage that reasonably chairman
we can
we can include
an expectation on this that
the inclusion of permeability is is a an
agreed uh item
so i think that's uh appropriate as a as
a um
an informative chairman i mean the flood
authority will ultimately have some say
in this but it comes back to ground
conditions
so i'd recommend an informative for that
the play equipment
the scheme has had various thoughts
about play play equipment over time
can i also suggest bearing in mind that
that already has a section 106 behind it
to
secure the open space and it's part of
that
that this is the subject of another
informative whereby that's to a
specification which
is agreed between
ourselves the applicant and the parish
council so that we have some common
sense about what what that standard of
equipment is so
two informatives uh would be part of my
recommendation to you to deal with both
play equipment and
permeability question
and then there was the question of
building regulations now at the moment
as i understand things we have 47 units
offered with pv
uh which includes eight affordable units
the applicants look further at that and
i think from their perspective uh they
they think they can achieve a hundred
percent provision of um
uh
p visa on all the plots where that's
reasonably practical by reason of
orientation
and my recommendation committee would be
that
there's effectively
an informative
and instruction to myself as chief
planning officer to deal with this as a
separate matter under condition 21.
so condition 21 is the sustainable
sustainability condition i think i did
mention earlier that that was already in
an acceptable format
and what we
have discussed has been the applicant
putting in a revised proposal which
includes
solar pv and on all plots where that's
reasonably practicable
and that's basically down to orientation
of plots and that we'll deal with that
under condition 2021 outside of
committee
the other point i suppose that i i would
pick up in relation to the footway
cycleway and the risk to
people passing along that
and the
potential for people to be um
hit by vehicles passing along
the route or by vehicles crossing the
curb
i think by estimation the curb as it
presently exists is probably
not as high as it will be once the works
are carried out
uh i think it's fair to say you're going
to have a three metre wide footwear and
cycle way
and
you know once the works are completed
you'll have a curb which will be a
technical standard of 125 mils high
i think
by anecdote the current estimation is in
places it's about 75 millimeters high
so there will be some increased measure
of natural protection by reason of that
to keep traffic separate
and
away from cyclists and
foot passengers on the cycleway footwear
but as i say
with that i i have very little space to
go anywhere because the planning
authority is in receipt of what was
expected
thank you
thank you look i mean that at least
gives clarity around some of the
concerns we're never going to be able to
cover all of them as a committee but
you know that was definitely worth
having that adjournment to give you that
opportunity so thank you and thank you
um to you guys as well for having those
discussions council plasmas back to you
because so far you've proposed it are
you happy that we put in those those key
points you know i'm perfectly happy um
with that and i think that's that is a
step forward and i think that should be
appreciated so i certainly appreciate it
as a proposal of this one other thing i
didn't mention but we did talk i think
earlier about um landscaping along the
railway line but i um i can't imagine
that would be a difficulty just to make
sure that that
um does meet the expectations of the
committee but that again the officers
have already got that so i think that
would cover it but if that could just be
specific do i have a second
for that
well i'll second it i don't normally
propose a second i'll second it
anyone else wish to speak or will go to
the vote at the stage
we'll go to the vote okay we'll go to
the vote
can you just remind us as much as you
need to on what we're being asked
i i haven't met well we've got i think
you have just been through the four
points and we and it's we've just we've
just had it read out so i think we're
all very clear on what we're being asked
okay members that vote is now in
progress four
four thank you chair
i'm sorry
um
council matters would you like me to
take further
okay so how would you like to vote
right
thank you
we got two more
councillor well am i you okay would you
like me to take your vote
counselor
okay
thank you chair that is four votes four
and two against okay
thank you very much
okay
right we now move on and sorry to keep
you uh at the back row there sorry it's
taken as long
i realize you've been here for three
hours waiting so i apologize but we'll
move swiftly on to that item 7b
and we'll just ask you to move seats any
speakers that need to come forward
okay folks we're going to move straight
on to the next item which is as i said
agenda item 7b
in part in mendelsham and part in
palgrave the line actually goes right
through the centre of the site
and i'll now hand over to alex scott to
take us through the application alex
thank you chairman um yes members this
is item 7b as the
chairman's explained application
reference dc 21 forward slash 0-4476
um the application seeks outline
planning permission
with all matters reserved apart from
access for the erection of 14 dwellings
and a mix of two three and four bedroom
dwellings is proposed
the site is at land at norwich road uh
weathering set come brockford at uh the
settlement uh brockford street on the
a140
and as as gems explained part of the
site uh lies within the parish
of uh stoke ash and through it as well
as uh weathering set sir come rockford
and i've got a uh a map showing that uh
i'll come to that in a second
so the application follows an extant
planning permission on the site for nine
dwellings reference uh dc forward slash
20
double zero three two four and this was
granted in october of 2020 by your
officers and uh delegated authority
and the current proposal is uh therefore
for an increase of uh five dwellings uh
further to that
extent uh planning permission in effect
now there is no proposal uh for on-site
delivery of affordable housing as part
of the proposal and a viability
assessment has been provided as part of
the application
which has been
assessed and agreed by the district
valuer
service as a request from your offices
as paid for by the applicant
and further elaboration of this point is
provided to you in
section
13 of the officer report so i'll just
move on to the
presentation
so this is the location of brockford
street within the district
and the approximate location of the site
within the immediate
area
and this is the an aerial view of the
wider
area setting of the site and settlement
and an aerial
view of the site and its immediate
surroundings the site is edged in red on
the plan there
and onto the constraints
map um now the site lies outside of the
uh settlement boundary which is uh
shown in edged in green here that is
from the uh 1998 local plan but it's
worth bearing in mind that that um
does denote that the settlement of
brockford street specifically is a
countryside village so notwithstanding
the fact that it's outside brockwood
street we still uh
view in the in the same way as sites
outside the settlement boundary as per
um
um core strategy policies uh cs1 and cs2
now the public right of way public
footpath number six runs past the rear
of the site here and
that is said to be a bride away um by
suffolk county council public right of
way as well
um
several grade two listed buildings are
within the historic core of the village
uh but those are
a significant distance away with
intervening housing development
in the order of 80 meters i think the
nearest one is to the south of the site
so there wasn't
too much concern about uh an impact on
setting and significance raised by um
your heritage officers
uh when they were consulted
now um the
dotted line which hopefully you can see
there through the site that is the uh
that is the parish boundary so anything
to the north is in stoke ash and throat
anything to the south uh whether except
camp rockford parish
and this is the redline site location
plan provided with uh with the
application
and this is the latest uh proposed
access plan uh now this has been
provided recently by the applicant and
it follows the um
comments received from county highways
so this has been submitted um
in an effort to address those concerns
um but
we have not yet received the um the
comments of uh county highways
specifically on this on this proposal
for the meeting today so um apologies
for that
and this is the uh indicative layout as
proposed now matters of layout are
currently
reserved so
yeah this is this is indicative but
essentially um what is proposed is uh
the majority of the dwellings fronting
the highway would be
uh
three bedroom dwellings um with one
two-bedroom dwelling
to the very south
you then have the
two semi-detached properties there's two
bedroom dwellings um then another
semi-detached pair of three bedroom
dwellings and the four bedroom dwellings
detached would be
at the back but um
yeah indicative
as
as is currently proposed
now on the screen here we have uh on the
left is what's currently proposed and on
the right is what um has already got
planning permission uh for nine on the
site just uh for comparison um
bearing in mind that the current
proposal that the layout is currently
observed so that you know that could
potentially change um
in
in any event
but essentially
the uh the dwellings
which are closest to the a140 would
essentially be the same the same design
and provision
that's a point worth picking up i think
onto some photographs now this is
looking across the frontage of the site
south
into rockford street village
and this is turning slightly to the
right
looking
again towards the village and there is
uh further housing behind this existing
tree screening and this is the main road
through the settlement and
note the 30 mile an hour speed limit
and this is
looking north
away from the village and you'll
probably be able to see the
petrol station and services which are um
in close proximity to the site and
there is actually a intervening dwelling
here at
ashley um which
neighbours the site
and this is the state of the site at the
moment and uh what is being constructed
is um the extent planning permission so
uh that's uh that says your officers
understand
and then just uh
photograph there with the interior of
the site
now in terms of your uh officer's
recommendation the recommendation is for
um
for refusal and that is on the basis of
the
9.54
years housing land supply the council is
currently able to demonstrate and it's
your officer's uh
assessment that um the objectives of the
mppf paragraph
6d are being
are being met by
by our current housing delivery and uh
we're now in much
better position to
implement the purpose of the development
plan um to manage the delivery of new
housing development
um to more rather than less sustainable
locations
now the site is not considered to be
sustainable um and for the following
reasons i said out in the report
but just briefly
inadequate access to a full range of
local services and facilities
by means of
alternative modes of transport
walking cycling and
bus connections
there would be a significant reliance on
the private motor vehicle as
the principal mode of transport to
access service and services and
facilities the majority of which are a
significant distance from the proposal
site in stone market dis or ipswich
it's not considered to be
there's no public benefit in terms of
affordable housing as none is
being proposed to be delivered on the
site
and
um
the benefits of five additional open
market housing is considered to be uh
minimal having considered our current uh
housing land supply position
and also there is uh not considered to
be any uh significant uh economic
benefits as a result of the proposal um
in the planning balance there
and there is a second uh reason for a
refusal uh proposed
in terms of
inadequate information in terms of flood
risk and for members information there's
uh
elaboration provided by the local lead
flood authority in the table papers
and um there is more information
required in terms of flood risk
assessment and infiltration results so
we're not so quite
there yet and we need that further
information so that is um a further
reason for refusal um absence of
information
thank you
okay thank you very much
uh questions
yes counselor yeah thanks i just asked
alex i mean the original application was
granted for nine and um the front three
or four houses are getting almost
complete now because it's uh very close
to the goals you say but was there ever
an anticipation or any discussions
regarding putting in for nine and then
having another five onto it at a later
date do you know just a matter of
interest
well um the
yama sort of at a disadvantage really
the previous one for nine was a uh a
different case offer and she's not no
longer with the authority
but uh yes there was no um specific
preamble on this yes i'm certainly not
trying to catch you at the the point i'm
asking this is because of course if you
give permission for nine and it is in a
30 limit as you're saying but next to
the garage but of course then adding
another five on there
could create problem but also um is this
a way of trying to avoid therefore can i
we could be very careful we're not in
debate now that's disgusting
you need to become the question i get
that but the affordable housing how does
that work if you have a nine plus five
as opposed to 14 in the first place
um well because of the size of the site
there was a requirement for affordable
housing on the nine anyway
um and viability was undertaken for that
application as well as i understand um
so you've you've had two applications um
one for nine one for fourteen they've
both been tested by viability um
yeah it's both come back it's it's
unfortunately it's not uh
seen as viable to secure even one uh
affordable housing on the site there is
a residual but
any other questions at all
no okay so we'll move on so next we have
the applicant we have paul fox and chris
collins we don't have the parish council
an objector or supporter so we'll go
straight to the applicant
so over to you and you have three
minutes um and if you can keep that
three minutes please
thank you chair good afternoon i'm here
on behalf of pride homes with respect to
the application at mereview in brookford
firstly i'd like to mention that
throughout the course of this
application pride have not received any
negative feedback from the district and
was in fact actively supported into the
committee report published last week
therefore i'd take this opportunity to
address some of the concerns raised
firstly environmental harm having as
little impact on the environment and
actively supporting its protection and
growth is something which is very
important to pride homes you can see
this through the design and inclusions
within the development such as saturn
live roofs on the garages solar panels
on each dwelling air source heat pumps
throughout and burn b boxes and
bricks
through the inclusion of five further
dwellings of the development it will
increase the living grass roofs by 135
square meters and pride plan on
constructing a wildlife lagoon hence the
name near view in the centre of the site
which will act as a wet area for nature
along with further bird and bee bricks
the transport links by the case
officer's own comments there is a bus
stop which exists to the south of the
site which offers daily services to dis
eye and ipswich the case officer states
that this that occupies would not be
reliant on private cars and would allow
them to utilize the bus route for
employment opportunities the president
has been set here sustainable transport
was not an issue when planning was
passed on the site for nine dwellings
and the same scenario will exist for 14.
furthermore pride homes have been
working with a public right-of-way
officer to construct a new access bridge
from the site and upgrade an existing
public footpath along the river dove
which will run from the site to
brockford green and into weathering set
which has further services and schooling
over developing as a case officer's
comments the proposed density for 14
homes is acceptable within planning
policy the permission for nine dwellings
is actually under developing the site
and is not making the best use of the
land a further fire dwellings will be
contributing to mid-suffolk's housing
delivery numbers whilst not using any
further land within the district
on this the district is currently
claiming in excess of nine years worth
of housing land supply in the emerging
local plan a large proportion of land
has been allocated that has no active
application nor any evidence that these
sites will be brought forward given the
uncertainty in the world and potentially
worsening marketing conditions
for this reason we would urge the
district to consider the definite
benefits of stitch application could
bring to the local community in the
short term potentially five additional
families living in the village providing
further trade to nearby services local
pubs and shops not to mention the jobs
created through the construction of the
dwellings all whilst not taking up any
further land in the district
the risk of flooding a revised flood
report has been submitted as part of our
application which shows there is no
reason to refuse this report has yet to
be reviewed or commented on
now pride homes aren't a large corporate
house builder they're a locally owned
father and son team who feels that every
development they do must positive
contribute to the community around them
they believe they can achieve this by
increasing the number of dwellings and
provide families with the opportunity to
live an environmentally friendly home
that has access to wider facilities and
services i would urge the committee to
reconsider the recommendation for
refusal and see the positives for
increasing the number of dwellings on a
largely under developed site thank you
for your time
thank you
questions for the outcome i've just got
a question i'm not sure if it's for the
applicant or for the case officer could
you just talk about the insufficient
flood risk information that's been
provided and where we are with that
um well gentlemen that is set up by the
lead local flood authority in the in the
table that's still the case that that is
quite recent yeah so can i just ask the
applicant why we haven't had the
flood risk and surface water treatments
that's required for an application
we have submitted a revised
flood report um
end of may
to alex
and to be reviewed so that does that
does show the site those drying away
and it's sustainable there's no risk of
flood
that hasn't been to has that been signed
off by scc
floods risk authority um yes i mean the
applicant's quite right we did receive a
revised report in may um however the
latest comments from
scc are still lacking so uh we need a
bit more
from them yeah
thank you
any other questions to the applicant at
all
yeah
sorry you
only if it's answering the question i
asked
yeah
um i just wanted to add on to that flood
report obviously it's quite easy to have
a condition that we can
produce more information uh regarding
that
yeah yeah okay
any other questions
no okay thank you for that uh so we'll
move on to the ward members now we have
two board members so i better do it
alphabetically
so councillor bern first
i should like to offer the following
comments for the committee
i represent the parish of stoke ash and
wait which includes the northern half of
the site
council stringer is the ward member for
the southern half which is the parish of
weathering set come brockford it was
councillor stringer who asked for the
application to be determined by
committee
i think i understand his reasoning for
doing so but i disagree with his
assessment that the proposed development
is in a sustainable location
i'm pretty
pleased to see that the case officer's
view on this is in accordance with mine
14 dwellings on this site would indeed
be over development as both parish
councils have observed there is a
significant difference between that
number and the nine dwellings for which
the site was granted permission in 2020
as explained in paragraph 3.1 of the
committee report
the relationship of the current proposal
to the emerging weathering set
neighborhood plan
as outlined in paragraph 3.2 also has
relevance
i have no doubt that the officer's
recommendation for refusal is a sound
one and if the committee members are
minded to support it
i'm sure they can do so with confidence
and then from council andrew stringer
uh i wanted to explain sorry i'm not
able to attend tomorrow's meeting
yesterday and could i please
read these thoughts circulated committee
i want to take this opportunity to
explain my reasons for the call-in
council stringer goes on to say this
site is unique in many ways notably it
straddles the border of two wards ahead
of the call-in i had spoken with
councillor byrne informing him i'd be
seeking a call-in
it is noteworthy that both parish
councils recommend refusal of this
application although for differing
reasons
the parish weathering set have limited
sites planned for housing and the
upcoming joint local plan
this site is a site that mid suffolk has
put in our draft plan
and it is the biggest site proposed in
weathering set come brockford but as yet
the soundness of this is yet to be
tested by the inspector
the site does tick some of the boxes
needed for sustainability
convenience shop and on a bus route
etcetera but wider employment
opportunities village hall and education
and spiritual centers are remote
from this location without a footpath
network that connects
two further reasons in this case in my
opinion would point to refusal as being
the most appropriate conclusion the
first is the avoidance of a contributing
sorry avoidance of contributing to
affordable housing
small settlements such as brockford and
stoke ash have little opportunity to
take forward affordable housing schemes
so when land sufficient to bring this
much needed affordable housing comes
forward
then to contrive an application to avoid
affordable housing contributions
strikes at the heart of making this
current application unsustainable
the second reason for me is the huge
amount of area designed to accommodate
parking and maneuvering the motor car
this current design appears to be
basically a car park surrounded by a
ribbon of housing with little or no
thought into how sustainable methods of
transport are being encouraged
thank you for taking the time to hear my
thoughts and that's from andrew stringer
district councillor for the membership
award
so members that's all the information
before it's up to us to discuss debate
and come to a conclusion
cancer field you want to go first
yes i i gather from that that uh
councillor stringer is against
uh the uh application the officers
recommend refusal
and so does the other ward member
so i have some difficulty in seeing why
we would take a different view to that i
would
move that we accept the officer's
recommendation and refuse
is that a proposal or just
i think that was a proposal
anyone else want to go yes councilman
the um
the the viability points it is
interesting it
it seems to me that the the point about
community infrastructure levy which
presumably is is applicable on this site
that part of the
purpose of that was to drive
um to drive development to to the places
where it could best be built
in cost terms
which would then allow the
the council's affordable housing
policies to
to deliver
um
and yet we're told the viability here
falls below one
one property um so
with 14 on the site so
it does it seems like it's the wrong
site somehow rather
and um so i mean i think i
i'm tending to agree
with with the officers on that i'm not
sure i'm going to
second it yet
i've got some thoughts if no one else
has got a hand up yes councilwell
thank you chair just very quickly um
i don't consider it be particularly safe
crossing the a140 to get on a bus the
other side
um so i would doubt the sustainability
it's not also not particularly safe to
walk along even
a footway alongside the a the a140 so
i'm yeah i'm concerned about that the
the layout i know it's only it's only
outlined but work has already started so
some bits of it appear to be
already sort of set in concrete so to
speak
so um yeah i'm not i'm not uh at all
happy with the layout nor the safety in
terms of sustainability so
sustainable transport so i i would
probably veer towards um
uh voting for refusal i'd like to listen
to others though that's so possible well
i i don't think i'm able to able to
support it
at this stage so i'm going to second the
motion because we do need to have the
drainage and flood risk assessment up
front we can't assess it without it
being there even if it's in the system
um and the other thing is that i'm not
very keen on the fact that if you've
already had nine and then you want to
stick another five and we've spoken
about
affordable housing and i think we've got
to be very careful we do need to have a
degree
of consistency there are always
exceptions but looking at this
application
um i do think that need needs to be
addressed and i don't think this
application in its current form
addresses it and we have to look at what
we've got here um
and i am also genuinely concerned going
on the a114 living here just up the road
nearly every day
the
traffic coming out of the site with more
more vehicles if they want to turn right
heading north there's all sorts of
complications potentially there with
people turning left and right into the
garage
that may not be strictly speaking
on the application here but i do know
that from personal experience since 1982
that is a major issue there and we do
get shunts and i'm not sure that yet
another tourney which is literally
but one place next door to the garage
has helped particularly for those who
are going to be traveling northwards in
other words turning across the um two
lanes of traffic to head off
so that's my view thanks
okay it's interesting this one because
when i first read the papers i couldn't
really see why
you know i struggled to some degree as
to what the difference really would be
between nine and a few more i felt
actually on the site it probably could
take it
but having actually heard the case
officer listen to the ward members and
obviously heard today's presentation i
do come down in favor of refusal as well
um and also i think you know we all know
that you've got to have the the
clear
you know the
the county council has a clear role now
in terms of flood response and giving
feedback on that so
with insufficient flood information that
is a big issue but the sustainable
location i think has been proven today
to me to be another reason for refusal
so i'll also be supporting the officer's
recommendation so on that basis we'll go
to a vote yes
sorry chair just to jump in there there
was just a couple of very minor tweaks
to the recommendation just just before
you moved to the vote if that was all
right i mean particularly minor it's
that we refer to a new dwelling rather
than the new dwellings um and again we
put one rather than these so just very
minor so can you just yeah of course so
at the beginning um we've had we put the
proposals in the countryside with the
development of a new dwelling and i
think that should be the new dwellings
because there are five not not one
very minor moment and then towards the
end um
it's considered that in the
circumstances of this application the
direction of new housing development to
more sustainable locations there's a
greater weight than the delivery of one
it should be these additional dwellings
so just so very minor that we had put
one rather than the five yeah
just that week thank you okay so i'll
hand over
to you for the vote please and
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress jer can i take your vote yes
so four four refusals thank you
councillor mathison are you able to vote
would you want me to take it
thank you
thank you members chair are there any
five members here now that is five votes
for refusal so that's unanimous thank
you
thank you very much so um thank you very
much so
final agenda items gender item eight
site inspections do any site inspection
requests need to be reported to the
committee
okay great well thank you everyone thank
you for and again sorry to kept you so
long for that
for the whole morning thanks everyone
let me close the meeting at one o'clock
you